[Music]
um do I start
yeah
I have to do everything around here do I
work for you uh
um so I haven't seen you in a while and
I appreciate you having me on the show I
have to tell you that
um you have the clearest cameras uh in
the podcast world
so I had to put a little nevy acute time
on the
on the face you look opalescent
Sebastian is that even a uh and another
thing your vocabulary is beyond any of
my comprehensions
let's dumb it down a little bit
[Music]
um let's turn these monitors off
so that I'm I'm not staring at
myself the whole time and how amazing
the peptides have made my skin look
I don't even know where to start with
you
well we share a history I mean we've
we've known each other for
what's going on what and when's it
when's it when we go to the Middle East
2005 together
I have been so scared of you for so long
why I thought I'd been really friendly
with you you're no you're so friend no
one has a more Pure Heart than Sebastian
that's very nice thank you but because
you have in um
you
have a I don't know if it's genetic I
don't know if it's ancestral we'll
figure it out you have absolutely no
need to impress anyone at any time you
need nothing from anyone ever you never
have
oh it's getting hot
I thought I was gonna keep the jacket on
the whole time I mean I'm in a wool
Bolero so if you're already hot
my future is Blake on this pod
um
you only talk if it's absolutely
necessary like it's your last resort
communication
like it's
such a it's so annoying to you to have
to utter
a word
so
when I was first started doing stand up
I was so insecure and such a projection
machine that like you walking in and
just saying nothing and needing nothing
and you're also like
it's this might make me emotional
um
you're also I want to say I'll say one
of the only comics
uh
that has no predatory energy towards
women
it's kind of insulting actually
never harassed me you've never tried to
have sex with me you've never flirted
with me and um I'd like an explanation
well here
um
thank you by the way
I I was thinking about this on the way
over
this really has nothing really to do
with not hitting on you or anything like
that but we we went to
uh Dubai or wherever Lebanon we sat next
to each other on an airplane and I think
prior to this or it was after this I
said hey
I could get you on
so and so it was like a six seven minute
set somewhere on TV where I thought I
was helping you out and I wasn't really
aware of what was going on in your
career and you responded with
I'm good
yes
so I always like oh I wish I would have
known more about her and what was going
on because like you said me not talking
to people a lot of times I don't know
what people are interested we were just
talking about Kevin Christie before I uh
we got on the podcast that he's an
amazing artist you know I didn't know a
lot of uh things about people at The
Comedy Store I had a group that I came
up with uh and I hung out with those
guys for for a little bit and then when
we started working I really didn't see
them but I I was not one of these guys
that walked around The Comedy Store and
like talking and hanging out you walked
in like a panther
like a mute Panther and he would just
prowl Around The Comedy Store it's
you're all energy you're all
observational energy and Sebastian would
walk in and immediately like he would
just recoil at negative energy and lean
into positive energy and he would when
when Sebastian from the beginning I
think I first came to The Comedy Store
in 2006 I want to say
I remember I was there with my backpack
I had my little backpack and my
you know um with all my childhood trauma
in it and I'm standing there and
I I think it's so important that people
understand that you've always been
Sebastian
it's like everyone caught up with you
but you were always
wearing bedazzled bomber jackets you
were always like when you would walk in
everything would just
um
be in slow motion everyone would stop
and you would just like walk down the
hall and it was like the Seas would part
for you I it's I didn't see any of this
it was your energy but it was just your
energy it was just that that kind of um
incredibly powerful energy and the
Italian ancestral
Mafia power I mean it was just like when
no one wants a horse head in the back
like when when you walk down the hallway
we're just like don't kill my horse
it's so far from who I am though I just
there to go up
do the comedy and and leave really you
treated you treat you showed me that
comedy is a job
yeah I guess that's what I looked at it
as not that I don't like to have fun I
really enjoy hanging out there I enjoy
the The Comedians but I feel like when
you came in I had been doing that for
eight years already I got there in 98 so
I've had my like fun at two o'clock
hanging out with the guys I've never
seen you at the comedy store with a
woman that wasn't your wife
yeah I I didn't I didn't I didn't bring
women there because it was like it was
like work for me I didn't really it
wasn't something where I I knew Lana was
your wife when you brought her to the
Comedy Store
you're wearing the same jacket we were
both wearing leather jackets with the
same studs on them or whatever it was
yeah we do yeah we and I was like that's
Apollonia
that's her like I when every I mean The
Comedy Store
the days that we were you know
concentric on it like
guys had a different girl every night it
was all about showing off their prowess
of how many girls I can get and you know
whatever
um you never had a girl with you and
then you showed up with Lana and I was
like oh
yeah Alana was you know it wasn't one of
those things I knew she was my wife when
we first met she was extremely shy and
it took me a while to kind of break her
open but once the floodgates but you put
a picture of her is your screensaver on
the first day I had uh no within the
first month I had her on my screen saver
it's legal criminal activity creep yeah
and my my sister's like she's on and
she's like what are you what's that I
know that's you know I put a picture of
Lana she goes it's been a month
take it down but uh yeah she was the
best thing that ever happened to me and
how did you meet
through a personal trainer we used to
share and uh I had asked hey do you have
any good looking women that you train
he goes yeah I got one at six o'clock in
the morning I go it's a little early I'm
sweating in here
I run hot generally but I feel like in
my sweater tears I think it's tears are
you trying to pretend that sweat is
serious this is a full this I'm in a
full I'm wearing a sweat and I don't
know how I'm wearing an alpaca it must
be so it must be your your peptides
um which I'd love to talk about anyway
she was
um
what was the question uh how did you
meet the trainer trainer trainer in the
morning I came in at seven I came in
oiled up three Stout what is it Gunner
John Petrelli okay great guy he um of
course what's that do you know John
alien no yeah of course I just I'm just
I the Italian ancestry thing we need to
get to itself yeah there's a lot of
Italians in my life
um
so I was hitting on Lana
pretty hard I was laying it on pretty
you met her when you saw her what
happened
I said wow she's really beautiful that's
her what did you were you like that's
no I didn't say that's my wife I said
I'm breeding with her no no no I'm just
so curious about it there's no there's
no breeding there's no nothing I just
saw what she's really attractive like to
get to know her uh John would kind of
like introduced us and I would flirt
here and there with her a little bit and
but I would come to the the gym like
like I was going out at night I mean
shower cologne Orangina
yeah baby oil
so uh and she had no clue no clue about
like that I was hitting on her she was
just really naive perfect yeah that
makes her even better yeah and uh it
took her out and then it was a slow burn
we went to
um
Sushi no sushi on third it's closed it's
right by Third in Los Angeles that's it
Sushi Roku and then I took her to the
Grove
and we had a little Pinkberry
Pinkberry
I think all was revealed that it was a
sham
Pinkberry was the hottest thing going
for a while yeah Pinkberry was the Coney
2012.
of yogurts yeah it was good though it's
a big deal no I'm a fan
um
so anyway yeah it was a Slow Burn
I was dating her when I went to
um
was I dating her
no this is what you weren't there where
were you there oh yeah you were there
the Dubai trip yeah
I did a private gig at the the Dubai
trip and that uh El Burge what were we
doing there this yeah yeah that's it so
I have a photo up on my computer of me
in a brown bathing suit from J.Crew in a
see that's like the front of the Burge
hotel that Sebastian took
who is there's a third with us right uh
it was black guy uh uh Tommy
Tommy uh In Living Color Tommy Davidson
Davidson Tommy Davidson uh Dwayne
Perkins
um Kirk Fox
y Dooley whoa
um
but you walked around the Middle East I
remember like you had been there before
people knew you you were talking to like
princes and whatnot I was like look at
this work in the room I think you were
making the deals to come back trying to
find a husband yeah so we went to the
Middle East together I wouldn't I
remember it clear as day uh getting on
the plane with you to go to Dubai for
this corporate gig for a shake have tour
wow you got a you got a better memory
than I do I don't know why we were there
I don't have tour I just have like
fragments
and um it was the first time I'd ever
fallen first class
and it was first first first first air
morocc Royal air maroc which is like
it's the Grove
in the sky
and we sat next to each other
and I'm writing always
I always so much where I was like should
I be doing this I was writing probably a
script for Whitney I was probably
working on the script for Whitney
probably because this is what 2007 yeah
around there I'm sniffling it's not
covid
um it's the dust from my house the show
was syndicated the check's cleared
um
and I sat down and I was next to you and
there was the map on the screen
that tell that the little plane that
shows you across the globe where you're
going yeah and you turned it on
and I didn't you're like because I
didn't know if we're going east to west
and I was like what is this and I was
like and you were like oh you turned
this on I was like who cares and he's
like Don't You Wanna
you're like don't you need to you need
to know where you're going I was like
yeah you were like in your own head you
were you wanted to see which direction
the plane was going around the globe I
wanted to see where we are where we're
going to be so if I woke up I could look
and go oh we're over to don't you do
that when you fly I don't care didn't
care
yeah I like to know where I'm at how
long I got left and I'm like because my
brain is like how do we even know this
is true
wow
it's like that's my brain when I see
someone a photo of someone sonogram of
their baby I'm like this is the same one
I saw the other one they they give they
have one
there's one they give to everyone the
same one wow I I had no idea see I I if
I would have talked to you when I went
to Hamish or I would have known your
Neurosis or these nuances of your
personality that I didn't know when we
went to uh the Middle East and I took my
shoes off
and you were not happy about it I wasn't
sorry I was right next to you on the
plane I took my shoes off and you were
like
it was everything I did you were like
I think I think it was more me sarcasm
me at 26 next to Sebastian on a plane
like me with my oils and my pills and my
things and my news everything was like
yeah because I didn't I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't know you really at
all no I mean we didn't really spend a
lot of time together I mean just at The
Comedy Store hey what's going on but I
didn't know a lot of the guys on the I
think at the time I was very scared of
you and embarrassed because like my
trajectory as a comedian in the
beginning and maybe you know I won't
speak for all female Comics but like the
inclination the beginnings to be very
blue and dirty because you're a woman
and you wanna
neutralize yourself or sort of
um
get ahead of it or uh be so gross that
it
um makes you masculine or something and
I always was embarrassed in front of you
because I was like I feel like because
my material is dirty he doesn't like me
I always had like shame around that
because I was always so impressed
by your craft as a whatever clean comic
means
so do you did you feel intimidated going
into a business where men are
primarily the your co-workers
I'm more intimidated by women than men
in the stand-up world
is it for females do you generally find
that they help one another in stand up
or is it there's a lot of competition I
think they've been conditioned uh to be
to compete because there's such a
scarcity complex there could only be one
like that was real so my generation of
women isn't very competitive with each
other
um and because your win is my loss if
you get the spot in the main room at 9
45 I don't get it you know it's me or
you you get Tuesday I get Wednesday you
know it's very much like that Rubik's
cube of The Comedy Store lineup
um I think it's changing social media
and podcasting has changed it Rogan's
changed it where we all rise together
like other people now other women's
success helps other women but at the
time it was also like when you first saw
me performing just bombing with like
period jokes in the or like
the onus was like one woman represented
all
so there was this pressure like if I
wasn't funny see women aren't funny told
you there was just so much pressure
because I felt like when I went on stage
I was representing all female Comics so
there was also that
um but yeah it was incredibly
competitive coming up
um
and now I mean now I'm in a different
position so I'm not competitive but I
can't speak for the girls that are
younger now
um but yeah it was like one one woman a
year gets The Tonight Show one female is
gonna
yeah get to see Mitzi whatever it is
so yeah yeah I do agree I think now it's
more everybody is lifting one another up
but I don't think that was true in the
early years of Comedy I think at all it
was me it was me versus you very much
with women
super Primal yeah I've often looked at
that from afar of women and how they
behave at The Comedy Store yeah if they
uh if even if the younger women go up to
the older women for advice or or what's
all those Dynamics like just because I
only know it from a male perspective
where
you know I think it's great what Joe
Rogan has done bringing it excuse me
sorry I'm just Judy marmel
what's your wife calling me about
placenta
[Laughter]
um so yeah I uh it's fascinating I think
in the female world of stand-up comedy
because I don't think a lot of men know
what the the ladies are going through
whether it be getting spots or getting
TV or what whatever whatever it is what
I was not privy to it interesting but
but it is upsetting a little bit I feel
like
to me the need to
go dirty like was that something that I
don't think that's listen I love to
laugh just as much as the next person
and a female gets on stage and and has
got great material and I I love it I
mean I I really enjoy watching funny
people yeah I don't think you have to be
a certain way to fit in or what have you
maybe as a young person getting in you
thought this is what you had to do but I
mean that's a that's a part of growth
but uh no I I just I just when I sit in
the back of the room I'm like come on
it's almost like casting
you know like when you're casting your
show you're like waiting for somebody to
knock it out of the park yes you want
them to win yeah and I just want to
laugh I just selfishly I just want to
sit in the back of the room and forget
my problems and laugh at the comedian
that's on stage regardless if it's a
male or female but
um I remember like Utah I mean what I've
learned from you is
um there's not enough time to
encapsulate all of it like
I remember there were times that I would
see you go on stage after someone
ate shit after something did not go well
there was not a it was not a personality
match between
um
the comedian and the audience and you
would go on stage and
I remember seeing you in the or like you
would go on you wouldn't talk for like
30 seconds
just to like reset the energy is that
conscious like how do you like how are
you so connected to the energy
of the audience
no I just think that's a feeling just
like you go up there you just gotta feel
it out whatever whatever you're stepping
into I think you're getting that
response right away without any because
I think the
you want to get up there want to grab
the mic you want to start talking
because it there's it's uncomfortable
maybe not to speak or to stay silent for
a little bit actually dice is a
brilliant at that not talking uh before
he like your use of silence is I love
silence no one's I mean you're The King
The King of Silence not from the crowd
not from the audience
laughs
your silence is conducive to a shitload
of noise
yeah I've always relished in the silence
and I think that's watching Johnny
Carson for years just coming up on him
watching him as a kid I thought he was
the master of do you watch silent movies
as a kid no no it was more comedians all
comedians all the time I never had cable
I used to go to my cousin's house and
watch he used to tape all the specials
and whatnot and I used to watch those on
a Saturday morning alone in a basement
and just used to study I used to be
fascinated still I'm like how does this
comedian sound like this is the first
time he's saying it how does he remember
this what is what is this all about I
used to go to comedy clubs when I was 16
years old with the girlfriend I had at
the time we used she knew the bouncer we
used to go in the back
snuck in Chicago yeah I forget the name
of the club it's in Rosemont it's no
longer there but we still go there
Friday Saturday nights everybody's at
Taco Bell
and I'm like I'm going to the comedy
club
so uh always fascinated with it never
knew how I was going to get into it it
was uh you know I come from the
northwest suburbs of Chicago my father's
a hairdresser my mother's a secretary we
didn't have any connection to
entertainment but I always knew I was
fascinated with stand-up comedy I like
to make people laugh I'm not a big
talker I don't I'm not the class clown
I'm not the center of attention I don't
like to be unless I'm on stage but like
when I'm around a group of people
I think the misconception and I don't
know if you're like this but yeah yeah I
got you might because you'd like to talk
more than than I do but I don't like
I like to listen
well that's why you're Sebastian
that's why you're the observational king
of our time yeah it's a great
observational
conductor yeah you're the
yeah I just like to observe I don't like
to like when I do these I don't do
podcasts a lot because I don't like
necessarily I know I'm pushing it with
this I know this is ruining our
friendship but I don't care no it was
flimsy to begin with let's be honest you
know I see people go on these podcasts
and they're like
giving all this information a lot of
people love to give a lot of personal
information yes for sharing sloppy how
they feel about certain things and this
and that
I grew up where you just didn't talk and
you'd never shared your intimate
feelings with anybody other than your
even your family didn't even know so
I've always been tight-lipped I never
take a side either way and I tend to
when I come on these podcasts
that serves Italians well huh
that ancestral uh yeah I think it's an
Italian thing especially sicilian's been
conquered so many times that we don't
trust a lot of people yes and it could
be in the DNA yes and uh yeah never
never a big talker so even when I go on
like Joe Rogan like you know Joe's very
gracious hey you want to come on the
show I I feel like
you know I I watch his podcast and he's
got like doctors and and David Goggins
he's got no toenails running the 150
miles I go I really got nothing like
that I didn't overcome anything there's
nothing really in my family like there's
no uh abuse or drugs or alcoholism that
I had to overcome so I don't really have
a big story to tell I just happen to be
a guy who grew up in the midwest like to
make people laugh and wanted to try this
out and and here we are Darkness I feel
like is very like you carry the
ancestral trauma yeah maybe maybe that's
it and maybe the darkness is that
there's uh I don't like you know if you
got to know me I think people that are
close to my family and close friends
that I have they see maybe a different
side of Sebastian than myself going into
The Comedy Store yeah I I know
cut that
uh play it on a loop
play it on a loop yeah
so but what where did your um uh
ancestors immigrate to in America
Mississippi
interesting so my father came to
Mississippi with his family because
that's where the rest of my father's
family was but they didn't like
Mississippi and they left within six
months moved to Chicago and that's
basically where they started their life
so this was in the this is uh my father
was 15 so this is 60s okay 60 around 60.
okay
and my father
was one of these guys he's a beautician
he's a talker he's a big character but
things that you know
don't tell how much people you make you
know that was that was a big thing
growing up that's not shame it's just
it's not Secrets it's omissions yeah
yeah privacy privacy privacy uh where
you know a lot of people in this day and
age tend to be very
open about oh look at what I have look
at that how have you negotiated that
with social media because I feel like
you just found your groove with social
media in the last couple months yeah you
know I took a pandemic took a pandemic
it took an invisible murderer
to get you to start fucking channeling
that because it feels like you I felt
like your relationship to social media
perhaps because of this ancestral
um magnetic uh loyalty to privacy it was
I felt like your relationship to social
media was adversarial
for a while yeah I couldn't find my home
there because it's the antithesis of
what you are about yeah secrecy yeah
well it's just humble yeah I didn't want
first of all I I'm like I don't want
people seeing my living room or where I
live or my kids but you know as
as I got to use it and whatnot I wanted
to share a side of me that was a little
peek behind the curtain and see you know
what what happens at home and whatnot
and I have fun with it it's not like I
over abuse it yeah
um I doesn't feel mercenary it doesn't
feel it feels it's charming and
appropriate yeah I feel goofing around
around the house and like my my thing
you like uncanceled Michael Jackson by
dancing to him the other day
I think you're just Invincible to
canceling
wait I put Michael Jackson to my son
dancing I thought that was I know I see
I would have fear I would go uh I can't
post Michael Jackson the documentary the
allegations if I uh the comments
yeah I mean I didn't even think about it
I I love I love Michael Jackson's music
and I just thought it was fun I like to
make people laugh so I used it now
during the pandemic as a way to kind of
get you know not going to get the stand
up laughter anywhere else but okay I'm
like I want to put a smile on people's
face uh I like to think that when I go
up on stage I'm making people forget
about everything outside the room
whether it be politics
whatever they're going through and I'm
like oh maybe I'll use social media and
that's it all right I'm putting lip
gloss on without a mirror
while looking at Sebastian in the eyes
oh maybe we should fire up the TV here
you need any powder do you need
no no actually I cooled down cooled okay
you it was touch and go there for a
minute I thought it was gonna faint
um do you have the vapors
what's that the vapors like the vapors
like a damsel in distress gets the
vapors see yeah don't start using
references yeah sorry I'm sorry it's ivy
league my bad did you go to Ivy League
school you did see that sort of I mean
not honestly but I I did but the way I
got in was witchcraft well did you get
through through basketball
uh no through
um gold digging
laughs
are you looking at yourself yeah okay
well no I just want to make sure that uh
the whatever I just did with the lip
gloss isn't see I look insane
the I can't look this insane for your
episode what's uh I'm gonna put my hair
back and be a lady okay yeah I look like
um time snap that I look like Kurt
Cobain 23 minutes in okay the hair goes
back the hair's back okay there we go I
have to have more respect this is
Sebastian's here you guys look at this
that's more elegant right that's very
this is better right Ariel again no okay
it's very nice
um that's very nice
you want to call Judy do you want to
call him okay on speaker
um I didn't know you played basketball
it's another thing I didn't know about
you uh which I found out like this year
I think talking to you in the parking
lot that you were a basketball player
which now it makes sense that you got
the basketball
but what did that what did that change
your perception
it
if you would have told them if you if
someone pointed out and then Whitney
played basketball I would thought that
was a joke I didn't I finally when he's
funny
finally a clean joke from Whitney no way
no I mean I just didn't put you in
basketball together huh
um
so yeah
man I just came to a complete halt there
no getting back on this podcast stuff
for me to do this and come on these
podcasts was this weird was this hard I
just it's it's one of these things where
I don't know where these things are
gonna go I don't know what I'm supposed
to be doing I don't know what's expected
yeah I don't know am I supposed to be
funny is this that people do the people
look at this and go oh is this guy a
comedian he's not making us laugh I I
never really know where these stocks are
so nice is that what it is yeah
jokes are canceled people want to know
were you molested or not that's what
people want to know now yeah can you
come out as a different gender like
otherwise no thank you I mean it's it is
it is interesting because I feel like as
soon as I figured out how to be of value
to people in a way as soon as I honed a
craft or a trade as soon as I had a
skill
as soon as I was able to Pedal my Wares
the skill that I had worked so hard for
kind of went away with the pandemic
right and then it was like oh wait a
second
um
I didn't want to start a podcast but
what do you I mean do you like
talking to people finding dude this do
you like this I'm in heaven right now
but I am very specific about who I have
on I don't have anyone on that I
wouldn't want to hang out with off
camera
so this is I can't fake it I'm a bad
actor like I can't pretend
in the first couple months was a little
touch and go if you guys see the first
couple months of the podcast I was a
little like I was a little like thought
I was on Leno I was a little like you
know still in the network TV
conditioning of like and stand up of
have to be funny every 20 seconds but
there's no audience here we're in my
house and the people that are listening
to this right now are doing laundry or
they're going running or they're
watching it on YouTube in their house
while they're doing their school work or
whatever it is so
it's it's kind of like a a brain share
thing and there's no there's no
expectations and you can't get it wrong
like it can there's no way it can go
wrong
I'm surprised that that
how how much how much could you listen
to people
Hawk I mean there's so many people like
someone else doesn't that like if I was
a podcast Hopper I go on podcast on
somebody else and then they're gonna
hear what the same thing I said here but
that's why I never ask questions that
you could find on another podcast so
it's like for me I'm not gonna go so
how'd you get to stand up I will never
ask you that and when I go on podcasts
and people say is it harping a woman
stand up I'm like I've said that already
so whoever's Googling me and is in this
YouTube Wormhole of me if that's what
they're doing because they took too much
Adderall or whatever
um they're going to see this somewhere
else so I'll never repeat myself on
another podcast or tell the same story
twice and when people come here it's
like when we had Lex on he's a the
biggest AI researcher in the world and I
just only asked him about his dad
because he's never talked about that
before yeah you know so that's what I I
try to do no I mean that's that's
that is unique in itself but if I know
something about you it means the
listeners already know it too or they're
going to find out after this they're
gonna go Google Google you yeah you know
but I think it's it's like about what we
our relationship
yeah no I I agree it's just there's a
lot of podcasts out there and everybody
is going on everybody else's podcast
like if I had a podcast that had guests
then you would come on my podcast and
then we're gonna do that that version so
I just find it that this is podcasting a
like a weird muscle I I always looked at
it as the UMP Corey alley do it just
wanna just wanna make people laugh
you're hanging out with your friend Pete
that's it
what's your connection to Pete I met him
in Canada on one of those like uh Little
Bus Tours I don't know if you I had a
crush on Pete Coraline you did one time
yeah really wow
like I definitely like saw him around
Montreal and I was like is that my baby
daddy
I remember having like is this my future
like Pete cory alley like this is my
dude wow I had a I was kind of obsessed
with him for a little while really did
he know
he does now
yeah he is thank you for letting me
project on to you
he is uh he's a funny guy so handsome we
had eight so Alpha so hot so hot is that
your time so funny like like Alpha men
Alpha yeah because you seem like you
would be in control of the relationship
I'm very beta in relationships whoever
I'm with has to be just super it has to
out Alpha me oh okay and and that you
seek that yes got it yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like man I can't emasculate by
accident because I'll emasculate them by
accident gotcha you know
um uh but Italian I have and I don't
know what it is I'm still sort of like
working through what in my
ancestral
um lineage but I have a very magnetic
attraction to Italian Benton's Italian
really
yeah well Pete would be happy to know
that Pete's happily married for 20. sure
his wife would be thrilled sorry it's a
compliment I'm happy to be your handmaid
well listen we'll we'll be talking about
this for 20 minutes on the podcast my
eggs are frozen we can just maybe like
freeze embryos you can have it we'll get
the story Lana can be the surrogate I
don't even have to see Pete frankly we
just I just my DNA like my primordial
reaction was like oh we need to like to
have an offspring wow
yeah so I mean great guy to pick is he
on rescue me did I make that up no okay
I know I'm complaining him with Adam
Ferrara because I did the tour with
Dennis Leary and Adam Ferrara but I
think Pete was on a couple shows on that
Rescue Me Tour oh Denis Leary yeah
yeah no he he has done the Dennis slurry
so that's I've done shows with Pete
before okay yeah
I just like have a crush on him yeah
he's a great guy funny cat so funny yeah
we have a way bigger career he should he
should he's definitely got the goods
it's just for whatever the reason he's
been a writer on a lot of these TV shows
and he's been doing that but uh stand up
wise I think he's extreme we're in Italy
is what's his lineage I think he's
bodies I think from Bari is that South
uh that is on the uh west east side of
Italy South interesting
um but yeah he and I hit it off and
we're like you know what this was in
2014 I said you want to do this
everybody's doing podcasting I said
every time we get on the phone we make
each other die laugh and I said why
don't we just do this on a podcast
and we did it and that's basically what
it's called The Pete Sebastian show I
know that you do it from like your home
theater
I don't have any I don't have any of
this I mean you're I also love that
you're like like out of frame for most
of it I love that it's just like not
even symmetrical like you can't even be
like you don't have a vertebrae when
you're doing it for some reason and I
don't know what you're holding like what
even it's a Brillo pad like what are
your microphones what did you say you
left a comment
I know Blair Witch oh yeah I mean the
camera work is very blurry no listen
listen you're vlogging over there I mean
I would love to get my hands on your
podcast like I'll do a literally do
anything if you'll just let me in there
no listen I've tried haven't I tried I
hate money
I had this company come in my producers
yeah and do a an analysis of what oh
yeah we could do this we could do that
yes and then the pandemic hit and it
kind of petered off excuses this is what
we have it's it's done extremely minimal
and I know and uh why don't we Kelly
worsler
to Kelly wersler it's gonna take five
and a half years to win follow Kelly by
the way follow Kelly wurstler is the
designer that has put um is why when you
guys have seen in my stories when I um
repost Sebastian it's why his house
looks like a Ian Schrager Hotel yeah
well it's we moved one we moved
furniture from one house to the anyway
that's why it looks like Alice in
Wonderland Sex Dungeon
oh God anyway the podcast is is poorly
produced I agree and uh it's just
something not even subtitled I mean it's
you hate deaf people you hate people
that have jobs that are listed at work
with no audio I mean it's wild how much
he hates people that have it's not even
that we don't even have the cable we
don't have the capability
to even because you won't respond to my
texts
respond to you also Sebastian changes
his phone number so frequently
how how what is it with you in the
changing of the phone numbers
uh I've only changed my number three
times over the last 10 years this is
this is my I'm sending you a screen grab
of this day this is in my address book
the number of times I have Sebastian
uh new phone number I mean the fact I'm
flattered that I get the text every time
but why do you change your phone number
so much nothing to do with real
friends that I have it'd be like people
calling me for um shows
uh Bookers you gave your number to open
mic I didn't have Bookers yeah I didn't
have like
um I wasn't like you you seem to be
dialed in with like oh I have like a
number I give to uh someone who wants to
be to do their show in a laundry mat and
that so I would I my number was out
there for a while with people who are
like hey do you want to do my show on
Tuesday night and then the hassle of
resp of getting that text is that not
tantamount to changing your number and
having to send out text your whole
address yeah but like as as there's not
a lot of people that even need to do
that for got it got it sir if you look
in your phone
I don't know about you my circle doesn't
really expand like right my contacts
uh-huh how many contacts do you have in
your phone 40.
but there's a circle that you generally
use right and how many people would you
say on it on average are in your circle
of like you're texting hey what's going
on or hey did you try to get what pen
interesting it depends it depends on
what month it is and what's happening
and if I'm touring and if you know it
depends yeah but do you ever go in
through your contacts and go who's this
delete
who's that goodbye you never do that you
don't do like a cleansing I feel like
with the change of the number it's a
cleanse and then like
it's just starting fresh yeah it's a
chrysalis out of the pupa
again
Ivy League
you don't like Riff Raff
you don't like rigmarole no you don't
like detritus
when I get home I will look that up and
let you know the answer you don't like
like
um
unnecessary unnecessary trash yeah
my desktop
one folder one folder
my when I do internet browsing one
window at a time so what is that
it's uh what's it from is it OCD it's
not it's not OCD it's just just like
order I don't like having I don't you
know I'm not an astrology person what
what just curious cancer because they're
wondering okay
yeah and my wife she's got
the computer's gonna shut down because
there's I go how do you find anything
you got 193 windows open
she's a type there's like 21
000 unread emails are you that
my texts
um wait how do I go to
how do you know how many unread texts
you have
doesn't it just uh show like a uh yeah
number on the think hold on but wait why
doesn't it do you have unread emails
um that's my unread emails 83
000.
like I see all this red you have
171 unread texts
12 out of misfaced I have no red
everything's clean
you have Windows behind Windows you have
no friends
no one wants to talk to you people stop
texting you 15 years ago
oh God no I don't know I don't know what
that is it's just it's order
Italian and male
Italian order
I have had a journey I have a whole
chapter in my book about my struggle
with migraines I have had them my entire
life and I'm frustrated that there is
now a company called Cove
that helps you find an FDA approved
treatment that works for your migraine
this did not exist when I was a kid
when I was a kid I'd be I was the one at
Disneyland that had to go in the car and
you like cover your face and you're
rubbing your temples and you're just
crying I used to my mind they left you
in the car at Disneyland yep that
explains a lot I my migraines have a
hundred percent Define my personality as
like a isolator like with no friends
that would be me like you're not ruining
this vacation go to the car I used to
but I got to the point where my fear of
getting migraines the anticipation and
the cortisol released of being scared of
getting one is what started causing them
like it was like I was in this like
cycle I could not break my left
um arm would go numb my I'd lose vision
in my left eye but when you have a
migraine you don't know you have it
because you have a migraine so you can't
really it's hard to do you know what I
mean like it's hard to know you have a
migraine yeah that's because you have a
mind which you can't think exactly so
like they're all so specific that's the
thing about migraines everyone's
migrants people like help me solve my
migraines I'm like I can't you you have
to but Cove can it's
perfect Cove can't because no two
migraines are alike and not only that
but Cove is completely online everything
it's all online everything's online
have a licensed doctor is going to
recommend you a treatment plan
customized for as little as ten dollars
per month I mean if the oh the fact that
this wasn't around when I was a kid is
giving me a migraine a few minutes of
your time you're gonna get a
personalized treatment plan for 20 plus
researched back to doctor doctor
recommended migraine medications
because there's a lot of things that
they don't tell you like that that Cove
would tell you like taking too many
medications for migraines can cause
migraines is it Dairy is it sugar is it
what time you go to bed every night is
it stress is that like and you don't
have to worry about your medication
because they've sent it right to your
door every month oh gosh which is
probably the if you have a migraine who
has time to go out and get medicine yeah
well going to get the medicine can give
you a migraine because you're released
in cortisol no insurance needed no trip
to the pharmacy all online Med sent
right to your door that's awesome and
honestly like this is something that a
lot of migraine sufferers were
perfectionists were
um uh over committed type people you
cause other people's migraines
is that we don't put ourselves first so
this is a great gift to give someone
else that you know that gets migraines
your mom your sister your wife or
whatever
um and force her to do it stop ruining
Christmas I got your code
com slash Whitney for 50 off your first
month of medication and free two-day
shipping that's 50 off your first month
of medication and free two-day shipping
at withcove.com Whitney Spell
w-i-t-h-c-o-v-e.com slash Whitney with
Cove
if you guys if I'm known for anything
it's my calmness yeah that's what I
would say it's the first thing comes up
on Wikipedia like when you think Whitney
Comics you think Serene peaceful
why are you always telling me to get the
calm out because well I love the Calm
app I've been a user for a minute I paid
for the subscription what does a minute
mean
um about a year okay yeah and I really I
mean I love it I like like you know I
like explain what it is I like ASMR and
all that it is but I want you to sell me
on it okay well give me a minute and
I'll try for longer than you have have
you now sell me on it well how come you
can never sleep then you've had it so
long
but um I like like whispering and noises
and quiet stories I like that to go to
sleep and calm is like it gives you an
option you can pick it's an app and you
can pick like different noises you can
pick stories people can read you can
pick outdoor sounds you can pick rain I
love the stories
I'm looking at there's a new one by
Mandy Moore yeah where she just tells a
story she reads a story and they read it
very soft and calm and it's like they're
so good it's like the Calm app is like
the mom you wish you have it's got It's
like be a baby it's like bedtime stories
from celebrities
oh my God
my God genius I love it
I mean we all love it sleep so why not
I'm looking I'm looking at the Calm app
can you read the rest of this while I
look at it
um
that's why we're excited to partner with
the com app the app is designed to help
you can you ease stress the best sleep
in your life yeah I'm talking to you
about it aren't you excited to partner
with them dude I'm just so stoked
and I'm a little insulted that I haven't
been asked to do it yeah because my
voice is not call me it can be
I think when you know occasionally
do it try now try now do you want me to
tell you a story yeah tell me a story
about uh the Itsy Bitsy Spider but
calmly
um
I'm such a perfectionist that I I I
would turn it into this is good yeah
keep going like um The Itsy Bitsy Spider
wanna can you edit that like I'd be like
did I start over this is good I'm
falling asleep right now I'd be I'd be a
perfectionist about how calm I was my
anxiety I'm not melting away is my calm
enough is this calm enough I've never
felt calmer Mandy Moore is probably the
one maybe more who didn't you say
someone from Penny Dreadful uh I don't
know her name but the actress from Penny
Dreadful who I adore hers is my favorite
one it's like to tell you a bedtime
story help you fall asleep it's supper
if listen over 85 million people around
the world to take care of their minds
and get better sleep I don't know why
they and if you go to com.com Whitney
you'll get a limited time offer for 40
off a com premium subscription damn oh
wow which includes hundreds of hours of
programming get the Calm app and
experience a transformation in the way
you sleep for listeners of the show Comm
is offering a special limited time
promotion of 40 off a calm premium
subscription at com.com Whitney that's
40 off of unlimited access to com's
entire library and new content is added
every week get started today at com.com
Whitney that's calm.com you need calm
after you listen to my podcast you do
from the chaos that I create it's such a
good now but
are there certain things you won't put
in writing
um because you because you call like I
remember when the the pandemic uh first
hit when covet first hit I was at the
Greenwich Hotel in New York City and you
were doing 20 000 seat arenas
20 000 tea Doritos 20 000 seat Arenas
twenty thousand seat Arenas um you
caused covet frankly
um Sebastian maniscalco's tour
um was spreading covet um the target
demo
[Music]
oh
and uh
I was like what's up with your shows
this was a Wednesday
Detroit had just hit Texas had just hit
cases the cases and I texted Sebastian
I'm like so are you canceling shows and
he calls me he's like what
yeah I felt like we needed to talk and
he calls me I'm like what
is Lana okay like first it's is she okay
is Annie are you okay no I felt like
that that was a discussion I felt like
Sebastian calls like I mean I was Ninja
okay
like I was yelling at the women that
worked in the gym Spa I was like
[Laughter]
like I was holding the phone out with
Sebastian newest newest newest number
I don't know I I just felt like I needed
to talk to you and then we facetimed you
mid pandemic well you were like but you
were like why would we cancel what's
happening what do you mean and I was
like well I think there's an invisible
pirate and people are passing away I
think this is well it wasn't it wasn't
that I mean it was changing hourly yeah
we didn't know where this was going
right no you were you believe that you
don't think it's a hoax don't worry no
one thinks that but you were like at the
buzzer we were at the buzzer kind of
talking to each other and then the next
day your whole tour was canceled yeah I
think what it was was we were out there
and then as we were out there people
were like canceling or had canceled even
before they left so I think we
I performed that Friday did you perform
that Friday no I canceled Detroit that
Friday because I was getting so many
texts on my community number about like
you know and we might have different
demographics of like Auto autoimmune
disorder people and older people my
mom's in a nursing home
um and also Detroit is who shut it down
Detroit and Houston the two markets I
was going to they their attorney general
shut it down okay so because my thing
was let's wait till they do it so I'm
not the asshole yeah that that was your
philosophy yeah
but I did cancel Cherokee and they
wanted to do the show it was a casino
they wanted to do the show and Baltimore
I'm just putting this on because now
you're cold no it's it's fine wait what
what's happening I need my Cape hold on
um
it's just that's what I do I got another
jacket a lot happening do you have a
wardrobe changes what by the way
um Paulo is Paulo yeah of course how do
you know him he did my um Amazon pilot
oh he did yeah great guy
um by the way um I have to mention
before I forget
um this podcast is one of the few
podcasts I came on can I show sure uh
Whitney gives a gift to her guests and
and the gift
um has a meaning behind it and uh for my
daughter
Seraphina she gave ooh its name I
guessed
you guessed it remember when we were in
yes remember we were in Art Museum
downtown
and did you guess that you were uh you
guys were pregnant this was when we were
not real friends but we were sort of
like
inherently friends we were at a an
exhibit for an Art Exhibit because your
wife Lana is an artist
um do you have this in your calendar is
that what you're pulling up uh uh
um was it the UTA thing yes UTA artist
space anyway this is a necklace with the
Italian flag from
Sicily in the 1920s and I thought that
was extremely thoughtful uh
and especially when you're giving it to
my daughter which is even better so it
was nice and
podcasters
I don't know if this has been discussed
on the in your show but
um
offered to send a vehicle to come get me
which is um where is it it's in here oh
let me just hold it up offer to send a
vehicle would have offered hair and
makeup as well for the ladies how great
is that for Seraphina
I want to know this woman that you get
this stuff from the history on this
thing okay yeah yeah no she's gonna get
it for you okay Megan my first assistant
and then a writer on Whitney is that
right yeah now like procures items that
are necessary to
unlock ancestral
Powers so what is this you've said this
three or four times during this
conversation this ancestral something
that you've recently got into to find
Behavior patterns of people what is
what's interesting when my father died
um your father's still alive very much
so
um when my father died I think something
happens where you sort of realize the
power of like your ancestor The
ancestral forces what you carry the
unresolved
emotional problems from what your
ancestors endured their trauma and how
they adapted because it imprints on your
genes genetically so it's like all the
work that I've been you know you saw me
at The Comedy Store bombing for years
with this talking about the female brain
stuff the neurology material then I made
a movie about neurology and both my
parents had strokes and uh you know as
comedians were professional observers
right we're like social anthropologists
and I'm always just trying to figure out
why people do the shit they do that's
what that's all that's our obsession
with Justice right our obsession with
why the fuck would someone make that
choice and
I could explore everyone else's but I
couldn't crack my own
and um all the madness you saw in the
early days uh you know of me when I was
like sort of
sleep you know at The Comedy Store
um I started real I was getting I
started getting a lot of answers to a
lot of the questions I had when I
started doing like family constellation
work and
um ancestry exploration of like how
epigenetics have been imprinted on our
genes and so Italian immigration to
America is fascinating for so many
reasons
um and my connection to it is Via West
Virginia in the coal mine industry
because a lot of them came as laborers
before the unification of Italy from the
south so there was a lot of Italian
immigration in Appalachia as well which
is kind of where my ancestry is from
you're Italian uh no no no Appalachia
Appalachia is my main kind of ancestry
Texas Oklahoma well you're saying the
connection you had to Italians the
attack is through because
um my great great great great
grandfathers were in Coal Mines with the
town oh with Italians yes and uh uh the
pepperoni roll do you know about a
pepperoni roll uh I know of it I don't
know the pepperoni roll was basically
invented by Italian immigrants in West
Virginia because they could last long in
a coal mine oh I met a woman I met the
woman that um wrote the book about
pepperoni rolls when I went to West
Virginia last year like I'm very into
the I'm very
and like the gesticulating and the
expressiveness and you know like that's
all from something and I'm just
fascinated at the way that our
epigenetic imprinting
sort of influences our everyday choices
and in the way it expresses themselves
so I'm fascinated by you because I very
much feel like in a way like my
grandfather was in a coal mine with
Italians and like were kind of in The
Comedy Store together
that coal mine yeah yeah
we get paid in coal in little bricks of
coal so it makes sense by the way
speaking of The Comedy Store there's a
documentary out on Showtime which you're
a big part of I mean you have a nice
sliver in that yeah last night's episode
you were you hosted you were the star of
number one on the call sheet how was
that experience
even that you know
I didn't
I didn't know what was going on with
this documentary yeah I didn't know if
this was just one of these things where
on Showtime Hulu the internet yeah I
didn't know I didn't know where I didn't
know there was this much involvement in
in the documentary so even even that I
was like oh is this what is this he
wants to film my set I didn't I didn't
really know what was going on with the
with the documentary so I was a little
kind of like
I didn't I didn't suspicious yeah
suspicious it was an inherited
suspiciousness that you have sometimes
it works for my benefit and then
sometimes it it bites me in the ass but
it is a superpower that you inherited
and is very Italian yes it is and and
I'd rather have it than not yes
when does it bite you in the ass
things like this the documentary you
know being a little bit more open to
doing things and not having such a I
wish you had done a better job no just a
little bit a little bit more available
like yeah you know like but but I think
you're a genius at understanding
um it's not even conscious like how your
value goes up with the perfect balance
of absence and presence that's in your
use of Silence you that you're inherent
genius at that we had Robert Greene on
the podcast
um and he was talking about this like
you understand that when you're absent
you're present in a more powerful way
maybe maybe but as a viewer looking at
the documentary I'm like
you're doing your interview here and it
looked like it was also it was like set
up here yeah Rogan's smoking a cigar and
like I was like standing
in the alley
yeah can we get this real quick you know
it was like one of these this your
interview looked like it was a
three-hour thing your Under Armor tank
top it's like what's happening
is that an equinox what's that I think I
was the only guy standing doing his
interview everybody's like sit down the
way out the door yeah
okay God so let's see but that is your
essence that is so signature Sebastian
it's so signature Sebastian to be like
I'm gonna just do the bare minimum
bare minimum sometimes though I would
like to give more than the bare minimum
but maybe like you're saying
subconsciously I just it's like an in
and out deal let's just get this and and
and get out but it's uh but it perfectly
complements your stage presence and your
use of silence and the you know the bare
minimum of saying words of like you know
ah you barely say a word on stage in
front of 20 000 people yeah I guess I
guess it's so it's it's a whisper it's a
whisper yeah yeah yeah so it it it's
congress with who you are
yeah but I again I don't want to come
off as being some loner that doesn't
speak to people
I enjoy the company of people that are
that I had a
I had a party as long as they're
talented and Rich no I'm one percent
it's not it no I'm joking I'm joking my
core group of guys no you just need your
people that vibrate you're free I think
I think you are
optimal
I think you operate in an optimal way
optimal way that's a good way of putting
it you're optimal I have a small circle
of Warriors only and only the people
that vibrate at your frequency and you
have no extraneous trash around you ever
energy I try to eliminate that and I
enjoy having those people over uh at my
home and having parties and whatnot I
really love to entertain yeah I really
love to entertain and what is that that
is the thing comes from the gym your mom
yeah our house was the house come on
like we're going to the nightclubs all
my buddies meet at my house drink at my
house
Roseanne and Salvatore they would they
sat down at the table and they
were part of the group Diane laugh and
my father and my mother were like the
the seventh and eighth friend of the
group they just didn't come out to the
club with us so that I think comes from
and working at the Four Seasons Hotel uh
as a waiter I think it's so I I know
people listening probably already know
this but when I started The Comedy Store
Sebastian was it was a waiter waiter at
the Four Seasons Hotel
would leave
to come to his spot at the comedy store
in his uniform and go home yeah that's
why I didn't talk to anybody I had a
table with chicken satays and a
margarita I had a film so this is great
that's greatness I mean that is
greatness
well that's uh where did Sebastian come
from what is this overnight success one
in the morning leaving his job as a
waiter at the Four Seasons to do 15
minutes in a comedy store for 15 that is
greatness that that like that that have
you fully processed the magnitude of
that
it'll make me cry if I really think
about it
um
I haven't there's a lot of things I have
in process yeah there's a lot of things
that I've done or I'm doing and I
haven't really stopped and looked back
and said wow you know I think I did it
two two summers ago I actually had a
time to like pump the brakes and and
reflect
what's that on your porch uh on the hood
and and uh
because I think that's a missing for me
not to enjoy some of the process because
you're always in it and then you're not
you're not really enjoying
enjoying it but did you know this was
gonna all happen for you I knew there
was big things ahead for me and that's
not being because it's not arrogant it's
not braggy or at all it's just I
remember seeing you and it was like
we all knew you know you're the only
comedian I've ever bought tickets to see
no where Peter Berg I brought to see you
at The Improv in Hollywood oh that's
right
to see a comedian and sat in the
audience
I do remember I brought a group it was
the worst night of my life to be the in
the audience of a comedy club because I
was uh in the back corner Booth
Sebastian's on stage I didn't realize
how loud the knives are everyone's
cutting their chicken and I'm like
Comics talking like I
was in the back like a psycho mom
because people are talking the waiter
I'm like shut the fuck up in your
Sebastian and silence is such a big part
of what you your art so I was like
freaking out because at the Improv when
you're silent it's just clang clang
clang clang clang forks and forks
chicken over there I think yeah I think
you kind of someone you asked someone to
leave that night it was like oh it was
also like a weird night I brought weird
energy into your space
you had to remember that yeah I bought
tickets and watched you do you're
because I always tell people like you're
the comedian that when you're on stage
I'll run in to see what you're doing
that's very flattering and I'm glad that
I like I like making comedians you too
Whitney I did that with you
you're the comedian I would run out
because you'd start talking about your
pussy I'd be like I heard pussy and I
that's it do I have a shift I'm gonna go
volunteer to work at the fourth season
so I don't have to listen to Whitney
talk about anal sex anymore
no your stuff I the stuff I enjoy most
about you is the stuff that I recently
heard not that I didn't like the stuff
before but
I like the observational stuff more than
I do like the crass rauncher stuff and I
think that and it I was the fact that I
did stand up in front of you at that
poll star awards show
that was such an out-of-body experience
I was so scared
um then I thought that material I
thought killed at that net it it did but
it is that is very heavily influenced by
you I think
well good I mean I I think it's for for
for you where you should be living
because the the writing was really smart
around all those observations like it
took me four specials to get there it
took me and maybe this is what I needed
to let the audiences give me permission
to start it's like I've talked about sex
for 10 years are we good can I now just
be a guy can I now just do what the guys
do you know like I've addressed it all
I've squirting and periods and I've done
it all now can I just be like I feel
like I finally am in a place where I get
to talk about what guys talk about
because I'm neutered or something I've
neutered myself or I've gotten to a
place where I
can't don't have to go to that space
um and I also think it's getting older
which is great uh but yeah no I mean
there is a joke that I think of you
every time I do it am I do I plagiarize
you uh it's the phone book joke that's
the favorite they throw it at your house
I mean that's kind of the Ross for Less
you take the shirt off and you just
throw it no that's when I heard that I
was like wow that's such a it's such a
Sebastian joke it's such a like I was
like upset that I didn't come up with
that because it's something I see every
year the phone book and and how the
difference because I like I like
Nostalgia type of humor about how it
once was and how it is and that that
phone book which you can't do till
you're older but you were always old for
something I was I'm
I was 75 when I was 21. always you were
always an old man
part of the reason your material works
you could always reminisce
because you were always 75. always 75
years old yeah it would be like when we
went to school we had to wear newspapers
around our feet like you were always an
old man yeah still am I still have that
mentality like even now as I'm looking
at the change of the guard of what's
happening in entertainment and how
social media and Tick-Tock and
dethroning yeah all this stuff is now
becoming
you know and I never wanted to be that
one guy that doesn't participate in what
is going on currently I think what we
are we're now the elders that are
sitting around telling stories this is
like we're recreating the tribal order
that's what this is yeah uh
I just
there's something to be said about like
what we went through as stand-up
comedians and even the comedians before
our time of of of working on something
day in and day out a live entertainment
being in front of a group of people
opposed to being behind a phone at your
house doing something
I mean it's just it's
just entertainment used to be an outlier
like it used to be something that you
didn't get into you weren't encouraged
to get into it you had to have some type
of talent to get into this and now it
just seems it's it's it's a lot it's
very watered down to me and I feel like
everybody is doing it everyone is it's a
talent show everyone gets to show their
whatever their skill is
I don't even think it's so much skill uh
it's tricks or they're yeah like I I
have video home video footage of me
doing quote-unquote tricks that no one's
ever seen that apparently would have
been good for the medium now you know
like I'm sure you have video of you and
your family doing hey that's cute you
think I have a family
adorable Sebastian really does know
absolutely nothing no I I I I I know you
have a family
um I don't know they're all drunk so
that yeah I would have actually looked
like Blair Witch Project footage it
would look like your podcast
I I don't know the intimate details of
your family life I know that there has
been some problems there but uh
the reference is more more to Like Home
Videos yeah singing in the mirror all
the stuff we did when we were kids that
was Private is now concerned for public
consumption which is fine I'm just
saying that clearly
you're clearly doing great with it yeah
I just but you have a but I think that
it it's it's the same but different
it's exactly the same but completely
different like I don't know if I did
this material uh uh that night when you
were there because I really did Panic
that night when I was performing and you
were there I cut a bunch of jokes in my
head when you were there when a comic's
in the room
that you respect you're really just
performing for that comic
is that right well like I was at the
comedy show when Jerry Seinfeld and you
showed up together like
what happens when you're on stage in
Jerry Seinfeld's in the audience versus
when you're on stage and he's not in the
audience is there any difference in your
performance uh no no I was just working
on some stuff that you worked on new
stuff in front of Jerry Seinfeld yeah
and and then there was some other stuff
that I knew that was gonna I was doing
my set that I always do at the comedy
store right it was nothing because you
were working on new stuff about like
swimming or getting out of the swimming
pool yeah learning how to swim yeah
um it was new
uh which is still haven't really worked
out yet but there's no like Jerry
Seinfeld he's here you want to do good
obviously it's not like you're gonna go
up there but it's like
um everybody knows every comedian knows
that you are going up and
try new stuff or you know it's not like
you shouldn't be adjusting in my eyes
what you want to do for a show like that
just because a comedian is in the front
row you'll probably lose respect for you
if it's a material actually what's up
dude go ahead and do your thing why why
would you adjust well because I it's
taken me a long time to delineate the
difference between writing for
fans audiences and writing for Comics I
think the first
maybe eight years I was writing for like
Ari shaffir
now it's like
writing for the comics in the back of
the room
to think I was tough resilient like it
was just like a see me as one of you how
could I neutralize wow I I never that
never even crossed my mind make the
comics laugh really um
I always looked as the comic as the
older like I never laughed so that was
weird that you were doing that because
you failed I'm I'm laughing more now
that you're not going after the comedian
yeah that's the because I'm like an Audi
I look at everybody as the audience not
like the comedians in the back I I could
care less if they're laughing I just
look as the coupe as a whole so I wanted
the approval so badly of comedians for
so long
well did you felt like you you got that
by doing what you were doing
yeah I think I do have it now and I
think I got it because of my work ethic
maybe not necessarily my performing
ability because that didn't come to way
later
when I started just copying you
[Laughter]
so
with all the stuff that's going on with
you with the podcast with your TV shows
stand up comedy is uh
after doing all this is there's a
favorite is is stand up still something
your brother stand Up's still my
favorite yeah and I think I I take
breaks between specials like big breaks
because I want to make sure that I'm
uh not doing a bad impression of myself
you know
um and so I was going to take a break
anyway after this last one to kind of
just like regroup and make sure I still
believed all the things I believed and
that like my I was like operating on the
most current software because you know
it's like
you know I don't do I really think that
about men do I really think that's true
is that cheap you know like I I really
have to update my software and
reevaluate and go like is that still
true is that still true is that still
fresh is that still interesting
um uh is that just a fabricated story
that I'm telling myself like
um and then the pandemic happened but
yeah I just went out and I did a bunch
of shows with Taylor Thomas oh yeah yeah
and it was like I was like Yep this is
it this is it and with the new material
I have which is all for lack of a better
word like clean it's like so exciting to
me because it's the first time I've done
stand up and felt like I'm not um
acquiescing in a way or like running
from my femininity or trying to like
uh neutralize with
um sex stuff
like like talk not talking about sex at
this point is the edgiest thing you can
do
um
but it took me so long to get out of
that and to not go like I know you guys
need me to disarm You by saying fucking
whatever talking about my pussy or
whatever you know what I mean just uh
make everyone comfortable it's like
women we kind of have to do that just to
make everyone comfortable
[Music]
and when you do these shows who is in
the audience who who are you performing
the these these uh uh amazing the people
it's distanced they show up they're in
their cars they're it's it's quite
different than birds I mean Bert
kreischer's Vibe is very I think
gregarious and more hedonistic than ours
me and Taylor like we like talk about
our you know
um the self-help books we're reading on
Instagram publicly so we get a very I
think more like
um
uh what's the word like it's it's not
like a party like tailgating Vibe it's I
think the kind of person that right now
is gonna buy tickets uh especially at
the prices that they're at which are
very high which I'm very serious about
my ticket prices
um because it's per car and you break it
up so it's like a ticket price they're
like 200 but it's broken up between four
people so you have to get people that
like can organize I mean it's a it's an
ordeal to come you know it's a lot of
rigmarole to come
um it's people that um
you know it's already like a
what's the word like a um a preset group
of people that I think are really like
conscious and
you know
care yeah aware mask someone was a mask
like everyone was like prepared everyone
bought blankets like everyone was like
optimal yeah you know
yeah it's just I I want to hear these
stories because I just don't know where
comedy is going after this or if it's
going to come back in a even bigger way
or is it going to come back and the
outdoor thing it it's weird because I
always was so against outdoor I never
did festivals I was never the like South
by Southwest
Bumbershoot fucking
[Music]
um cluster Fest person like I just like
I did those a couple times but I always
hated doing comedy Outdoors because I
associated with like competing with
concerts yeah and shit
um but they figured out the sound and
they have these giant monitors people
are kind of used to preferable to look
at screens anyway at this point because
they're so conditioned I mean for
performers like I'm gonna put myself in
your category sorry but like you're so
visual anyway you need screens to
amplify your face for the last row
anyway you're already using screens I
mean the key is the camera guy that's
shooting yeah and making sure that he's
we did have a little bit of a um
trip up in Denver where I was watching
Taylor's sets and I was watching her do
better on on her her jokes weren't
getting what they deserved and I
realized that the camera guy was just
cutting at the wrong times you know so
getting the camera guys to cover you
properly because you're basically like
kind of shooting a special that only
airs one night so they have to cut at
the right times but you need to zoom in
on your face anyway I think it's going
to be outdoor on giant screens
what's wrong with that nothing's wrong
with it but it's just Outdoors tends to
give you a what you love to tan it's
perfect yeah
um Vegas was good Vegas was great that
was your first performance in eight
months yeah so they did one ounce uh or
two outside and then two inside so the
inside was better just because I think
Tommy's better enjoyed and endorsed yeah
and well I mean this might actually
be a
180 or 360 really I that's not my strong
Cinema woman
um from us performing outside at a polo
match in Dubai
on a fountain
was that a was that at the fourth season
we were on a um I don't know how you how
you remembered us we were on a pla I
have pictures we were on a platform and
there was a uh we were performing there
was a polo match behind us in front of
us
um the fountain was going off I mean we
had to dodge the the
dancing Fountain I mean I remember
seeing you up there having doing your
Ross for last bit like dodging Fountain
yeah
yeah that comedy's not made for outside
it's just not
but the sound systems have in person and
the sound is great it's fine I'm just
saying the intimacy of this thing it
says the man that plays twenty thousand
students I get it I get it even that it
has a roof yes so I'm looking for places
that have roofs stable Center as long as
it's
uh yeah so I don't know it's just
interesting time right now I I kind of
don't I've been concentrating on other
things other than stand-up comedy but uh
movie TV show
things that I didn't have time to do
touring but I know you don't have a
passion for TV as you say I don't it's
it's not like I gotta get my own show
you have your own show yeah I yeah we we
have our own show we take it on the road
yes so in order for me to take it and
stay home
it's got to be really really good and I
have to really I don't want to do 26
whatever episode I want to do small
small batch small batches yeah I want to
I want to do I like doing acting and
making people laugh and that
form
um but uh for him as a trip Irishman was
really really fun to do I had a lot of
anxiety doing that and I I how are you
not so scared I was I was frightened I
didn't sleep for two nights prior to
doing the first scene I didn't know you
know what I just did I don't know that
world I don't know movies I've done few
you know come in one day just like us
just like us such like us now they're on
that reference
um tag small yeah you've been in small
movies small nothing nothing big but
then the Irishman was one of the biggest
movies that I've ever been in and
playing with De Niro and Pesci the first
day is a little daunting so I uh but
they're fans of yours I don't even know
that I don't I don't know anything going
in I don't know if they know I'm a
comedian you don't know you just don't
know you know like the guys at this
level you don't know but they're in all
of what you do that's what's so wild is
when you walk up to your Heroes and
they're like
because what we do standing in front of
20 000 people and talking for an hour
that is the scariest thing to even the
people you look up to
it could be daunting
to look at what we do and go wow that is
I could never do that or whatnot but
everybody has their our fears my fear is
going in yeah that's yeah that scenario
and going I don't know how you do this
with a guy with the thing and this is
supposed we're supposed to be acting
like we're at the Copacabana and we have
to do it 40 times the same way in front
of the same people but they've heard us
do it already that's that's when
stand-ups go into acting the whole Magic
of stand up is you everyone you're
surprising everyone they're hearing it
for the first time and then you go into
acting and you do it once and they say
okay great do it 30 more times you're
like but everyone knows what I'm gonna
do yeah did you feel that way on your TV
show where you're like okay you're in
live studio audience okay reset we're
gonna do it again
did you feel the pressure to do it a
little different maybe a Nuance or
something to give the people a different
look at it it's interesting because like
it took me a while to figure out the
difference between performing for the
audience and Performing for the camera
and Marty calner who uh directed my uh
second and third stand-up special who's
a genius I'm so grateful he was like
you're doing it for the camera not for
the audience in-house so you know my
first Bachelor I was like I was like
screaming because I wanted the person in
the last row to hear me uh but the
people watching at home through the
camera they don't need all that they can
hear you they have a whatever Blu-ray
thing that's
um
maybe the hardest I've ever left The
Comedy Store was you trying out your
Blu-ray ship my Blu-ray Blu-ray Blu-ray
you don't remember that you had a
Blu-ray bed and it has the Blu-ray did
you never end up putting that in a
special no oh I remember it you won The
Comedy Store one night and we're like
the Blu-ray
you guys have a Blu-ray
yeah I know you remember
the Blu-ray you got the Blu-ray you just
said Blu-ray like 16 times in a row
there's like Blu-ray Blu-ray no it was
like you um uh like short circuited and
just said Blu-ray
it was hilarious oh God don't even
remember it some of the bit like I have
so many there's so many iconic moments
of you at The Comedy Store just killing
for other comics when we were in the
back of the room
um of you walking on the airplane and
your bag holds a banana
I don't know you don't remember that
you sure this is my son this is a
hundred percent oh no you you came on
you were like the people
um
the TSA guy chewing gum and that that
went into special right the TSA guy
chewing gum no what
yeah that went in a special but is it is
the banana thing that you went on the
plane and you were like people have all
these bags oh yeah because you go I have
a bag if it's a banana yeah small
nothing it's a banana
yeah I didn't put that I pictured a
little like a construction worker from
the 20s with like a pail with a banana a
little sack
with a stick with a sag on the back yet
no I remember I have so many Vivid
memories of of you at The Comedy Store
working on material that maybe just
never made it
something about that place where you do
stuff and it just it just it happened it
could happen one night yep
and then you forget about it that's why
I started recording the sets because my
memory shot I can't even remember what
the hell I'm doing up there anymore on a
multicam it's like it's it's it's so I
don't know how interesting this is to
people but I think for me it's like
there was so much hate and negativity
and bias with people people have said um
at the time that I did that multicam
people were so uh
multicams weren't cool they were popular
but they weren't cool and
the word laugh track got in the
Zeitgeist and people started thinking
that it was a laugh track which is so
ironic because the show that I did uh uh
with um crystalia Two Broke Girls
um Chuck Lori's shows they all had live
studio audiences but the shows that
actually had laugh tracks like How I Met
Your Mother no one ever came for you
know so I was soup so what happens when
you're shooting a live studio audience
is if I say a joke Sebastian's here
um whatever give you know whatever joke
joke they laugh if I do the same joke
again they're going to anticipate the
laugh and laugh a little sooner and it's
going to be fake so that's why I always
have tons of alts on show night just to
sort of trick the audience so that the
real audience would laugh later
so that it would sound fake so you'd
have to fake out the audience so they'd
sound real well exhausting and you got
to take the microphones out of the
audience which I didn't know until later
but I like doing it in front of you I
mean it's it's interesting our our sort
of antipathy towards uh uh multicams now
because it's like that's what we all
grew up on Seinfeld and cheers and
that's even what the Next Generation
grew up on are the Wizards of Waverly
Place and Duke and Josh and Josh and
Drake and whatever the fuck all the
Nickelodeon shows
um but at the time it was like the
office Community Parks and Recreation
all those shows were like the sort of
Harvard Lampoon cool kids group uh
were like you don't get to sit with us
you're mainstream you're trying too hard
to get their approval and I'm like yeah
I'm trying really hard I mean that was
the thing about me everyone's like she's
ambitious and she's a try too hard and
she it's like yeah I'm trying really
hard to make people laugh I'm not being
like I'm gonna do my Harvard jokes and
you can take it or leave it I don't need
your approval like I'm like I need your
approval and I think that desperation uh
was really unattractive to people
because it was on such a mass scale and
from a woman like that neediness you
know you've never had that kind of
neediness no I I just remember when you
had that show you literally were
everywhere I remember I remember
ubiquitous
look that up
um yeah I mean the promotion and that
your face was literally everywhere I was
like wow this is unbelievable but would
you like this is what did you think we
were like uh-oh no I was like this is
this is great look at that I was I can't
blend I go I asked her if she wanted to
do a five minute comedy blend Central
it's like yeah on on Super Deluxe on CSO
I'm good I got her a spot on MySpace
what an idiot but um
did you ever were you like uh oh
no I was I was I didn't know I just like
you got a TV show so you root for other
Comics see when I when I was earlier on
when other Comics got things that I
wanted or felt I deserved I would get
very jealous and and
I remember going back to The Comedy
Store after that it kind of all happened
and I felt like I I worked so hard to
fit in there and like build a family
there and get everyone to like love me
and then I felt like I was triggering to
them and that I lost that for a little
while yeah but I think I remember seeing
you there and I don't remember you being
the person I knew prior to that I felt
like you were under an immense amount of
stress and I think you were going
through some stuff with your family
maybe I just knew that you seemed a
little bit out of sorts how was your
experience when you made your sitcom
pilot uh I um I love seeing on your
Instagram now so weird oh yeah I put I
put it I love that it's like airing now
it's out and doing bigger ratings than
it would have if it had gotten picked up
I said here it is to put out your sitcom
pilot that didn't get picked up on your
Instagram now
wild I had it I said why not love it it
was it was it was it was a lot of work
which I I I love work but
um you know coming from stand up and
doing what I want to do when I want to
do it to you know a lot of people a lot
of people giving the opinions and
whatnot which is fine I like to
collaborate but it just it wasn't the
right Network the fit for the network
and myself wasn't I don't think right
but I had a good time doing it I met a
lot of great people and uh
the fact that we are sponsored by hoop
is such a big deal the fact that it took
me this long to become a professional
athlete is really it's I mean it's about
time I just I know I've said this before
but when such an amazing product is
available it just makes me angry that I
haven't had it my whole life the amount
of time I follow the same way the amount
of time I've wasted like beating myself
up over not knowing how my workout was
or like I don't know how many calories I
just burned running should I do another
run tonight like just like for someone
who's a perfectionist like me like I
just need to know I don't care what the
truth is just tell me the truth so then
I can act accordingly yeah that's how I
feel because I feel like I would
work out or do things and I'd be like
this isn't doing anything it's not doing
anything for me stories I'll like fully
walk on the treadmill for 20 minutes
while drinking a Slurpee and be like I
just had a good workout or I'll like go
on a three-hour hike and be like I don't
think I worked out like I just yeah I
always fuck I don't do anything and then
the BAM will be like okay but actually
you did better than yesterday and I was
like did I know am I amazing thank you
it it's just the truth it's like it's a
way to Google yourself without it tells
me to go to sleep I think it's it's like
a good Google of yourself yeah the
Google alert of the stuff you want it's
like you know what yesterday you did
good but today you did great it's like
you're gonna need to sleep a little
extra because you earned it and I'm like
I do need to sleep extra it's like the
way you described it was the best it's a
personal trainer a life coach a
psychiatrist it's everybody the Internet
it's a full sports team of coaches and
cheerleaders it's everything you would
need to stay motivated times I wore it
on Joe Rogan it's waterproof by the way
when I wore this on Joe Rogan I was like
trying to gesticulate with this hand to
impress him like I got a loot band like
you were like as an athlete I was like
it's like the way some women show off
their engagement ring off my whoop band
like no big deal I have a woo band I'm
together I slept so well I really do
think that if your list guys are
listening to this you're probably
um firing us but um uh I do think there
should be some kind of like if you're
dating someone like can I see your whoop
band stats that is something you would
do it would save me a lot of time
weekly monthly performance reports tells
you how your lifestyle decisions are
impacting your sleep recovery and
training you might find that alcohol
really hurts your recovery and that
melatonin really improves your sleep a
ton whoop is highly personalized so I
mean it literally says in the print
ridiculous amounts of information it's a
ridiculous amount of information it
truly is I mean it tells you so much
right now we're so stressed out about so
many things it takes the stress off of
wondering God and you know when people
come in and like uh like every time you
ask someone how they are they are going
to say they're tired it's just like I
just send my whoop report it's just a
habit like I'm so tired it's like okay
well oh my God I slept eight hours it's
like well why are you tired then it's
just like let me see your whoop score
you're not that tired stop complaining
yeah I mean it tells you where coffee
I'm so tired asleep you're describing
yourself I literally it was a spot it
tells me everything about like your
heart rate and everything which I found
very helpful because introduced
respiratory rates yeah whoa an increase
in respiratory rate could be an
indication of illness before you start
to feel any other which is helpful um so
you go buy respiratory rate is a little
bit different maybe I should go get a
Cova test yeah maybe I should maybe have
a sinus infection Whitney Cummings
helpful for me because I thought I was a
ghost all this time because I turns out
take I I don't take my own uh data uh
um
um evaluation of myself seriously I'm
like I have a I feel like my heart is
beating kind of fast ah whatever I'm
probably just nervous like I'll downplay
it but the whoop band is like nope okay
I guess I'm gonna fucking no my heart
beats fast like this is what it's like
to be alive get that checked oh no
that's what it's just like to be around
me because you're in love move is
offering 15 off right now with the code
Whitney at checkout go to whoop
w-h-o-oop.com and enter Whitney at
checkout to say 15 sleep better recover
faster and train smarter optimize your
performance with whoop today
we talk about Better Health a lot on
this show
it's a good fit it's a good fit it is a
good fit we both need it they basically
when just sort of like how the sausage
is made um
you know people like the ad sales people
come to us and they're like which
companies do you want to work with and
it's like better help that's that's the
perfect fit for us anything with help in
the title we need
and better Hub is great especially on
the holidays because the holidays can
bring up a lot of trauma drama and
conflama for people and better help you
can log online you can just log right in
and talk to it there but before you see
your family your mother-in-law your mom
your dad you're just talking about it is
making my heart break yeah all better
help both match with a licensed
professional my inner child is waking up
and ready to cry I'm a licensed
professional under 48 hours you can be
talking about it that I don't like to
just keep reading ads as if the
listeners hearing it or the viewers like
for the first time we've talked about
better help before you know what it is
online
professional therapist you can reach
within have a therapy session with from
anywhere anytime anytime you know what
it is but why if someone hasn't gotten
it yet what do you say to them I would
say once again the holidays are coming
up yeah and you better log on and by the
way New Year's resolution don't be
fighting over eggnog yeah okay don't
don't cry over the marshes don't ruin
yams exactly don't ruin Christmas
because you didn't want to talk to
somebody you're going to drop the the
family gravy boat and your aunt is going
to have a conniption because she's a day
drunk but that's not and you're gonna
think it's your fault and it's not
everyone's gonna go back to being five
years old and their ancestral trauma is
going to come up and you're gonna you
know what you're gonna do look
everyone's family has issues everyone's
family has issues problems for the
solution
you're going to try to talk to the crazy
person
and that's that that means you're insane
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result when you
can just go you know what it's not my
family I'm not going to blame them I'm
going to get the hell behind what I'm
going to do I'm gonna go to better help
and schedule an appointment my
Thanksgiving or Christmas dinner
whatever holiday dinner whatever you
celebrate I don't care
is at five I'm gonna go in the car at
four take this call I'm gonna come back
in and help make the gravy I'm gonna
quit myself with the tool of let me
release all my resentments to someone
else so I don't take it out on my mom
who quite frankly doesn't have the tools
she didn't have better health yeah and
then you can come back in and radically
forgive her yes don't bully her with all
your
freaking she made you cranberry sauce
you monster she just wants to love you
and you feel criticized you feel
attacked by her love but now it better
help it better help you'll feel great to
start getting the help you need no
resentments no jealousies no passive
aggressive shit so don't wait you can go
right now visit rolls off you visit
betterhelp.com water off the duck's back
visit betterhealth.com Whitney it's
better h-e-l-p and join the over 1
million people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states special
offer for good for you listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
Whitney
I think what's happening in the pandemic
is like we lost Sports
I think when Sports went away it was
like people have this need to drag
people it's like the Roman the very
Italian the Coliseum you know like we
there's a very
um intense tradition of the shot in
Florida like the humans need to watch
other people be humiliated and
embarrassed and it's like how we gather
information of how other people so that
we can
not do that you know like we like our
dopamine like reward circuits uh fire up
it's like when you drive by a car crash
you have to look you have to see what
they did is a survival mechanism
um so I think that what's happened in
the pandemic with cancel culture getting
particularly intense
um Sports went away so now it's like how
are we gonna do you know about calcium
historico in Florence
calcio
oh this is a I how do I know more about
Italian History because you know what
what you went to a school
that uh that you actually left with
information right
I was talking to my wife about this like
when I went to
um College I didn't leave with nothing
like I went to the classes
not even that my parents paid for my
college so I didn't leave with a debt or
anything like that but I didn't leave
with knowledge I left with uh I was the
president of my fraternity and I and
what yeah no that is shocking to me what
fraternity Sig pie what what is it
what's up
what does that mean what is it I don't
know Latin I don't know what's Sigma Pi
I have no idea no clue I didn't ask what
what's the brand of that sorority
fraternity yeah
sorry what's that I have not know
nothing about Greek life the brand of
like what what type of people are in
there every fraternity has like a flavor
a brand A vibe this was like the Hugo
Boss of fraternity this was like the
Emilio zagna
this was like
there was the Phi cigs who were the guys
who were very
um preppy going to get a really good job
out of college got it trust fund kids
yeah
you know yeah we were state rapists no
yeah Brett Kavanaugh got it we were
you wanted you want to go dancing
you go to our house because we would be
down there
like literally
me and my buddy George were dancing to
what we just we had a dance party okay
yeah like after hours they called it and
we were if you wanted to go dance we
were the fraternity Sugar Ray just
blasting just
that was our Jam so I believe that's
black box is that black box I believe so
yeah I think you should have posted on
your Instagram for BLM oh God Black Box
I mean you have to have really engage
your core I mean you have to have abs to
really dance to that song
I love that song just one giant Kegel
that song
yeah my uh my fraternity no one wanted
to be the fraternity president and I
stepped in because I I didn't wanna I
don't like to see Things Fall Apart
and I used the chapter meetings as
somewhat of a of a like a stage in
audience what are you looking up
is the only National Honor Fraternity in
existence Phi Sigma Pi is unique Phi
Sigma Pi does not detract from other
existing organization it complements our
members tend to be some of the most
involved students on campus yeah that
was the other fraternity that wasn't
mine oh Sig pie
you're gonna see so yours is the yours
is the skin tag of Pi Sigma Phi a little
offshoot pie a good pie dancing the
first thing that comes up is is Sigma Pi
a real fraternity
so goodbye no I think this is the same
one uh founded in 1897 at vicenes
University
Sigma Pi over 230 chapters with 11 111
currently active
headquartered in Nashville did you read
any of the paperwork as the president I
don't remember that's the president of
this fraternity what can you tell me
I could tell you the handshake okay is
it oh the website's a.net that can't be
good yeah it's just kidding it is a DOT
Org the owl
owl it's an owl is that the is that it
is that the
this is a Boy Scout Troop pedophile
they must have changed the mascot
I think it was an owl I was there I
think it was a guy dancing
she's better and strong roller skates
oh God yeah it's just Ritalin and Zima
you were dance party guy yeah so I was
the dance uh the dance fraternity yeah
but it was a good experience for me I
got to I got to like be in charge of
like 90 guys is it what's the light like
what's that like like what does a
fraternity do for guys in school so my
reason I was anti-fraternity when I got
there I was like I ain't doing this
there's a connotation of the fraternity
being like uh you know an animal type
house and I'm like I'm not doing that
but I went to a school Northern Illinois
University which is an hour from where I
lived it was called a suitcase College
because it's so close to Chicago people
went home on the weekends so social life
you really had nothing going on if you
didn't belong to Greek row so me and a
few guys I met in the in the dorms
decided to pledge second semester I had
a 1.2 grade point average out of four
1.2 grade point average yeah my first
semester at school my uh my roommate at
the time was a nudist I had no idea
and he must be killing it on Instagram
right now finally the world caught up to
his skill set
so anyway I joined this fraternity it
was best thing I ever done because I met
some great friends and uh we had a great
time I mean some people back down with
oh what are you paying for yourself
that's so Italian uh what fraternity of
a Brotherhood of Man a pack of men yeah
it was with the kissing on the mouth I
we listen I'm not that Italian I know
but what is that I don't know it's I I
appreciate it because it's the most
masculine but also they because they
lean into their feminine isn't that
interesting yeah I didn't grow up with a
lot of Italians but Italians like they
can wear jewelry they can kiss each
other on the mouth men can hang out with
men and it's not gay or bitch there's
some do you know what I mean this is
fascinating to me isn't that every
culture I mean men hang out with men and
it's not misconstrued oh in I mean in
America you can only hang out with other
men if you're watching men fight each
other on TV or if you're watching I mean
maybe not your house but like if guys
want to hang out like when's last time
you got a guy's number to hang out in
America
uh can I get your number what do you do
with someone if you meet a new guy
friend I met a new guy friend recently
where and we all golf
well you have to do a sport together
um in Italy they just sit around and
gossip like women
yeah I don't think you find a lot of
like come on over and hang out on my
couch although you know you know Mike
young is is a good guy for that yeah he
comes over and we just hang him in your
Comics you met the work yeah no I mean
listen there isn't really a hey let me
get your number and go out for a cup of
coffee if you did it to another Italian
guy give me your number what are we
doing
give me a kiss
you just start making out am I wrong
no I think it I think you're right in
the sense that in Italy that that's in
the culture it's baked into the culture
there's a feminine there's a a uh
there's a a lot of feminine attributes
are channeled by men and it's not gay or
bitch or
is is
getting a cup of coffee necessarily
feminine it depends on the cup and the
kind and the wear and the context asking
a guy to get a cup of coffee that's a
date
I don't think so here it's if you ask my
producer to get a cup of coffee
you're together
no I I so what now we I go hey you want
to go grab a a tequila uh that's that's
cool
coffee no good but what the tequila I'm
not getting into your pants when's the
last time you went on a coffee date went
together we don't do that it's just we
don't I never really did that yeah but
in Italy you walk by groups of men
having coffee there's just something I
said about cultural Behavior men in
Italy lean on other men and have
networks of met this is a giant
generalization generalizations paid for
my house stick with me but it's like I
just I'm fascinated by the men that come
from Italian ancestry and they're
ostensibly feminine qualities in America
gesticulating cooking uh talking kissing
on the mouth
um connecting trusting keeping secrets
these are all like
pathologized as like uh tricky female
qualities
in Western culture cooking cook okay
women belong in the kitchen the men in
Italy can cook yeah so having someone
over for example to my home entertaining
serving
yeah that's that's I don't I don't look
at that as
female Western born men I think do the
woman that's the woman's job in the West
yeah well I uh no I never looked at it
that way it's a feminine uh
traditionally feminine in the west
Behavior
do you look at a man that does that as
having a feminine quality not if they're
Italian
dead serious so if they're Italian it's
hot so it's got you got to be Italian in
order to yeah it's a skinny white guy
from Silver Lake starts cooking for me
I'm like I cannot fuck you now you work
for me
it's human I mean it's like you know
what I'm saying let's order Postmates at
least Jesus Oh my God it's an Italian
men can do it you have permission and
can get away with it I I think you're I
think it's
could be European
um heavily I think you're going to take
your opinion close enough is your
opinion heavily geared towards Italian
men
um Italian men providing is masculine
American men providing as you're a bitch
uh uh what is it what do you call a
you're whipped
the women serve you
and there's a the way that Italian men
treat their women is so different the
respect
well I mean some would disagree and say
Italian men generally are you know
playboys and lotharios yeah but but
not in a creepy rapey way
I mean you know
listen nothing makes me feel sexier than
an Italian man flirting with me
listen it's Italian people in general
yeah
are very magnetic to be around I mean
just going out with Italians yeah it
there's always this passion yeah I think
it's a passion yeah where some cultures
don't have passion it's just it's yeah
yeah vanilla and yeah we're in it so
intense so emotional yeah how did you
propose
like the there was a hot air balloon I
mean like it's like intensity
everything's got to be big my wife is
not one
for surprise I can't surprise her yeah
and since I can't surprise her I did it
in a way where it was very in the course
of the evening I
her family
um is very regiment in going out to
dinner and and scheduling so when we're
at dinner when her family we're talking
about what time is breakfast that's how
I love it they want to plan it out where
I come from a family we're at lunch and
that will bleed into dinner all right
just because we're so much there's so
much talking and whatnot so long story
short her family were at her her parents
house her uh stepdad and mother were
waiting for us
in the car
and as we were walking out I had the the
ring behind the a little coffee machine
how long did you have the ring before
how long were you able to I had it for a
month hide it from her I knew I was
gonna do it in in to me that's like
every man gets to be like
um an undercover spy when they have an
engagement ring because you're just
spending right a lot of movement yeah
where'd you hide it
um I I just hit it behind this coffee
machine but the whole no no I had it I
had it in a suitcase with me I had it
inside me I swallowed it where was it
for the whole month oh I had it uh uh it
was in my dressing room in my closet
um
took it to Florida we were going I go
listen I got something to tell you
I took out the rain I'd drop to a knee
and I proposed she was like
oh my God we gotta go to dinner and I
was like
because her family
her family is the type if you ain't down
it
seven o'clock the beeping calling so she
was a she didn't want to upset her
family I get in the car and she goes we
got she's like we got engaged yeah I
wanted to have like a moment up there
you know like a like a you know like
it was like
okay nothing
and then she you know she definitely uh
in the car was uh she was just like
she's like that she's like my my wife is
so
kind and thoughtful and she we had a
conversation private conversation
yesterday about her kindness sometimes
biting her in the ass and uh she's
always worried about what other people
are going to think codependent yeah
so yeah
yeah but I wrote a book about it
wrote a book about it heard about it
what's a book called uh I'm fine and
other lies
pretending he's not a fan listen listen
writing a book
enjoyable nope
you wrote themas every day for a year
no Ghostwriter you wrote it yep you
wrote the book yes wow yes
who's gonna write a book for a comedian
yeah I use a Ghostwriter I don't I can't
write you're having a ghost writer write
a book right now yeah well you're gonna
well it's not a ghost writer either why
don't they just transcribe what you say
yeah okay yeah you just have too much
money no no I I rather I rather tell the
story about the story because yes it'll
it'll take you out of it if you're
writing while thinking
yeah I think that makes sense for you
because you're so emotional and like
your stream of Consciousness like
I um I'm a I'm like a writer first
you're like a visual
performer you know what I mean yeah I
think it suits you it would slow you
down I mean it was like I'm writing even
when it's not for anything it's just
like that's just High process yeah it
would take me longer to tell someone a
story than it would be to just write it
myself okay
so
but don't you think sometimes with a
Ghostwriter or a someone else in the
room would they would ask questions of
you that you might have not thought
about I have many personalities that
chime in okay but that's and this is you
work with this
um that's interesting because the
questions prompt you or like that's what
the reader would be thinking yeah it's
just challenging you to go well how did
you feel about when your father died no
but I have feelings so I would already
do that I already know how I feel I
would already think I would not it's all
feelings
yeah but but not every question is
explored
yeah no mine is the opposite mine is
like um you've been talking about your
feelings for five chapters where did
this happen mine would be the inverse of
yours
I lost you yeah so you just said how did
you feel about it the only thing I write
about is how I feel
it's the logistics that I would leave
out
okay
the listeners get it I'm not saying they
lost you
I'm not saying I'm not saying that that
maybe I'm losing something by not
writing down
feeling only you know your strength well
I'm so fascinated what is it with your
feelings like you just don't talk about
them you ever been to a therapist uh I
have twice uh different ones no just the
same one twice yeah
um
listen can I can I be a little bit more
can I
improve yes that is a real long
for a podcast wet the lips a little bit
this is just you you could just uh come
off a six mile jog guess what I'm over
here measuring out my sips this one is
doing a half a half a stanchion and I
moved the microphone so I could just
dude I'm white trash this is how we
drink oh my God I'm using I just need a
hose I'm literally just
um no so I only let there be twice and
uh like it's not like you need it or
anything I'm just fascinated by your
ancestry what you come from and men in
general like like like
it seems like you're very close to your
emotions yeah I am
yeah I'm very close to my emotions I'm a
little too emotional I think
um
but I'm very connected why are you
sanitizing your hands you know what I
felt like an hour in you got you got it
I started what if you need hand spray
that's germaphobe spray if you need it
this is your own line uh no no no
[Music]
I'm working on my skin care line we are
working on that that's good that's what
you should that's happening I know you
uh Sebastian it's
um I want to talk about the times that I
have been lucky enough uh to uh be
um so fortunate is to have you approach
me at The Comedy Store
it's happened two or three times I mean
if Sebastian initiates a conversation
with you at The Comedy Store like that's
when I knew I had made it oh God so but
instead of like tolerating you
tolerating Your Existence if he's like
come here I'm like oh like I have
something so bad and it was um
I think that was the first time we
really talked Sebastian was like where
so what's going on
all right so what are you doing with
your skin going yeah
yeah I was fascinated with the skin the
skin care and now Lana is is that the
line I go yeah that's Whitney she's got
it dialed in yeah yeah she's got she's
got the Amazon packages now or all for
me at this point
I'm not I'm not into
um
what you're sending
why not threatened that I can provide
more for your wife than you can uh not
threatened at all just look I'm feeling
abandoned no I don't like it escalated
put it this way I've made your wife feel
ways that you have never made her feel
not at all hurts it hurts just bought
your daughter the best president you'll
ever receive it hurts a little bit that
I'm a better father than you oh my God
I don't like anything other in the
refrigerator other than food
that's basically the no my creams go in
the fridge the creams go in the fridge I
know my wife is doing it on me now when
we go to sleep she's like you gotta try
this it's not something the Derma roller
we rolling oh she tried that we ain't
doing this well yes we are yes we are oh
yeah
feeling she she did one wrong she said
has this lighting so
not everyone's this generous to their
guts oh God by the way it is clear here
whatever you're doing here and like I
said it's is it the lighting or the
cameras it's all you just don't because
you pop
I don't do it
my producer just had it he's just the
quit
um
yeah you know your facial regimen was
was extremely intense because you you
when you knew me back in the day I I
probably looked 38 then and I probably
looked 25 now yeah how has having
um a daughter changed you and your
understanding of women
um having kids in general has changed me
but having a daughter for me
I had a problem with
women no with um
her not giving me the attention at first
because it was all mommy
um what was her first word
um Mom
and my son's first word is ball ball but
uh
it's amazing the connection at least in
this situation between and it's it's
with my son too and my my wife
breastfeeds and that's another layer so
I felt completely third wheel yeah I so
much so where I had to take a walk
around the block gather my thoughts and
going when has it become daddy's little
girl because Daddy really
you know it was always Mommy Mommy Mommy
Mommy Mommy Mommy and then always would
run to her and this and that now we're
starting to see Dad who showed her you
on the television yeah you started your
show to the Irishman like we now eat she
gets it now
no clue but we this pandemic if there is
a silver lining has given me the
opportunity to spend time with my kids
that I would never have had had because
I would have been on the road not that I
didn't want to I was just I was I was
touring yeah but you know it's it's
it's uh put it this way kids have
definitely made me more of a patient man
I was not patient I'm still not patient
yeah but with kids
it's it's just a whole different game
with them just so enjoyable a lot of
work also something that um I Heard via
Neil Brennan uh via Jerry Seinfeld
um that actually made me I think I've
always known I was going to have kids I
didn't know in what iteration or how I'm
going to do it or whatever but I was
always like I could adopt or I could
whatever it's like I rescue dogs like
isn't having my own kid kind of like
getting a dog from a breeder should I
adopt you know like I always sort of
um but I heard that Jerry Seinfeld said
every time your kid runs up to you it's
like they say that you laugh the hardest
you've ever laughed and then they walk
away and come and he's just like it's
the hardest I've ever laughed it's also
they're just so funny oh yeah they're
really funny they're really funny
it's great it's great I would highly
recommend
and this is what I want you to do and
this is what I see for you is
falling in love and getting married and
starting a family in that order
I I just think and I'm speaking from my
own experience having the sharing the
joy of raising kids with Lana
sorry a man
a man a man that I love
yeah I I it's
I'm all about family yes I grew up in a
nice family they got divorced later on
in life but I grew up in a fun family
and there's there's a part of me that
wants to have my kids grow up the same
way I grew up but obviously it's
different uh but sharing that with
someone that you love I think is
there's no replacement for it yeah
there's nothing worse than the wrong
person and there's nothing better than
the right person yes yes you know I mean
I'm not knocking people and I don't know
if you were talking about just adopting
a kid and you just doing solo I could do
that for the third one or the you know I
could do that like I mean buy one later
you know
yeah but it's just for me when I'm
running out of stand-up material or if I
need Instagram likes I'll get a kid
later why not build a brand
you make me likable relatable
I think it's it's
when your parents got divorced was that
hard yeah how old were you
uh one of my 47 so it was around
30. wow wow I don't think I really have
talked to anyone that went through that
as like an adult
yeah that was uh tough
uh I didn't expect it that's the that's
the problem I I looked at my family as
what I want mm-hmm I want that
relationship I want my mother and
father's relationship they're always
laughing like this is great it's
unbelievable and then it fell apart and
then I always thought I would call my
house and my mom would go on they wanted
to babe talk to your son now I'm doing
two phone calls you know two separate
phones so it's just like the hassle
it's your phone bill it's your minutes
you're worried about you yeah I am
worried by the way also this is not what
phones look like anymore
is that what I was doing what did I mean
who does this yeah like I don't know
like this is feels this is so so sick
pie
um yeah so it was very very different so
it was like having like your sort of
Paradigm like Crush yeah
and uh you know now
you know I my mother's 75. she lives out
here she's been out here for probably
about nine years and it's great uh but
you know obviously in an Ideal World I
would like my parents to
enjoy get back together well enjoy you
know the grandkids as a whole rather
than a separate so but it's all it's all
good and then have you and Lana like
what is like what do you really fight
about like because it's like I feel like
it's it's so fun to watch you're like
she takes forever getting in the car and
I'll be right back in the Amazon
packages it's like nothing is funnier to
me than those sort of like it there but
that's endearing to you was there ever
any like this is a real
difference
no uh doing backflips down the stairs
was that ever handstands none of that is
out of there the monkey the Clutter like
was there ever anything that was like
because I'm fascinated by the things
that bother us in relationships and then
when it's the right person all of a
sudden it doesn't bother you anymore
it's actually cute and Charming
yes but I mean let's be real here
there's going to be things that your
boyfriend your husband wife do that is
not in line Maybe
because my problem is I can't Comfort
like I can't compre I can't let
something go I can't compromise and I
don't know if it's because it's just not
the right person if it was the right
person I'd be fine with it or if I
really need to be not settling this hard
uh I don't let things go
uh so I don't think that I mean that's
just but there was no deal breakers with
Lana there was no like
no you know as different as we are it's
religion
um we're not super religious so it
doesn't really come into play raising
the kids
um yeah that's hasn't really been
something that how much do you lie to
the kids in terms of
Santa like what like have you had any
conversations about like what
we tell them Tooth Fairy are we hook
line and sinker on all that Santa Claus
is Santa Claus there's no like
explaining who Santa Claus is but
there's no you're getting up in the
middle of the night
and making the note yeah
what do you want to do you're lying to
your children what are you one of these
you're lying to your kids it's a fantasy
I'm just curious I'm curious they're
gonna be lied to their entire life by
people what Santa Claus is all of a
sudden harming the kid and we live in a
democracy same thing I'm fascinated by
what this next generation is going to do
differently what are you going to do
differently than your dad
listen uh not a lot not a lot of I love
yous around the house growing up
not that I didn't I knew they loved me
but it wasn't mentioned yeah that whole
generation yeah it just didn't yeah
didn't say it yeah
um we say more now than we did Growing
Up uh but like do you make eye contact
while doing it is it under your breath
all right
yeah
it just wasn't something
in the norm like my sister is my best
friend
I couldn't tell you the last time I told
her I loved her
I mean it's been said in moments of
Despair or moments of like
you know like
I love you but like you can't do that or
like you know no like we we maybe had an
emotional conversation and at the end
like I love you Jess you know it's like
one of like it's like it's like a
punctuation yeah I guess it was more
meaningful said in those ways than to
say it every day but like I'm throwing I
love use to my daughter I don't think
I've ever made eye contact with my
brother Marshall said I love you
I didn't even know you had a brother
I don't
I've got it do you remember when we
walked around Dubai we went to a water
park together in Dubai
went to a water park
we did on slides we like went to a water
park we walked around we I have I'll
show I'll send you all the pictures of
us we would like take pictures of each
other in front of the pool this is
before you got moved to the Burge Hotel
which is like the if Sebastian was a
hotel it would be
it would be the birds it's actually
enduring me that I don't remember the
water park we went so long I just
there's pictures of it yeah me you and
like maybe
Kirk fox or something we went to a water
park
um
no I I I don't remember that I feel like
I I went to your hotel room in the in
the Burj Hotel yes I remember which is
like to go to a male Comics hotel room
and there to be absolutely no sexual
energy is so hilarious I wanted to show
you the room I know but that's so funny
because at the time I was pray for so
many male comics and for Sebastian to be
like come to my hotel I had no power at
the time I was not successful at the
time I was the hottest I've ever been
and you're brown brown bikini
my doodoo brown bikini
pre-breasted plants
anorexic as it gets Italians love when
women's thighs don't touch
pale as can be uh and he's like come see
my hotel room like that like that would
have been something Ronan Farrow wrote
about if it wasn't you come to my hotel
room in Dubai it was like a two-story
yeah I was just I was the elevator was a
made of a fish tank yeah it was just so
cool I didn't have anybody there to
share it with yeah and I was like hey
you know you want to come and take a
look at this like when when when do you
go into a hotel like that so that that
was my mindset it was not like yeah no I
but I know but it's just it's just wild
looking back
at that
yeah it was like that's wild
to think about when I started The Comedy
Store it was like when someone would
bring me up the intro was like are you
guys ready for a lady
like that was how the intro would be and
everyone would be like and then people
just start wrestling and like go feed
their meters or get that was like a cue
to like go to the bathroom
this next comedian is beautiful like huh
like so before you got on stage people
were already like oh this is the
intermission
so let's let me let me ask you this
though do you find it being introduced
as a beautiful woman
something that bothers you
would anyone ever introduce you as
handsome I hope so
ladies and gentlemen his Jaws could cut
glass
the man is an Adonis he looks like a
Grecian statue
the president of Sigma Pi
no I mean it's just it's a weird thing
to involve your appear my appearance in
something where I'm about to perform and
the skill is verbal and you know what I
mean it's not about that it's not a it's
not a beauty contest it's not it's a
weird thing and then what are you gonna
do then some com female Comics aren't
introduced is beautiful are you gonna
say the she's not that attractive
I don't know I I just I never get I've
never gave it that spin
like if I'm going to describe you as
beautiful well that to me just means not
funny
I hear because it's very this next
meeting is very
very yeah I don't know I I don't
associate the two
if it's something I don't know okay
when is it like men are attracted to
women and vice versa in some
yeah so is it we cannot
say or describe a woman as being
beautiful
at all no no no no then oh for sure when
work yeah is attached Italian guy being
told he can't tell a woman
I gotta call Mike I gotta make some I'm
gonna send some text messages on the
threads guys
so no but it's in a workplace
where my appearance is not the Dr like
the uh you'd never say she's uh she's
very thin she's five eight do you know
what I mean like you would never it's
like you're telling me whether or not
you'd fuck me in my professional
introduction to the people I'm about to
that I'm because comedy is all about
being in control and being in power and
it's a way of just like doing a quick
degrading in front of the people that I
need to be powerful in front of you know
and it's not wrong it's not I'm not like
you know I feel like I'm very middle of
the road with our fair with this stuff
but it doesn't happen now
no one introduced me like that now
because I'm not pretty anymore
[Laughter]
this comedian used to be a catch in her
day
you should have seen her in Dubai this
comedian aging not so gracefully Cedar
on Craig kilborn
um it's just interesting that I don't I
don't have any charge on it I'm not
going like feminazi on it it's more just
like it's interesting I've never heard
someone introduce a male comic uh and
involve their appearance
I've done it in a in a in a joking way
if a guy is good looking yeah this guy
is stunning yeah and I think any guy
that's done that to me thought they were
helping in some way and being nice I
don't think their uh intentions were
malicious do you remember when we were
in Chicago and a comedian got on stage
while I was performing
we were the Just for Laughs Festival in
Chicago a midnight show at a theater in
Chicago I don't think I can tell you the
name of the theater
and I was it was like a dirty show or
something which is weird that you were
on and it was a midnight show Just for
Laughs Chicago that wasn't me it was you
because I was on stage
you wouldn't think I had like a drug
problem
no you just didn't right you just
weren't interested in me you just didn't
clock you were there but you weren't
yeah but like someone getting up on
stage when other comedians on stage
something I should remember it was I was
on stage and I was actually doing quite
well which is shocking for that time
period uh and uh the audience started
heckling so these two guys in the
audience started heckling me which for a
comedy store comic is like your dream
like it's great and some guy yelled
you won't remember this because only I
heard it like I'm gonna fuck you with a
knife
right it's a rough thing to yell but I'm
a comedy short comic like that's my
wheelhouse like great I get to know I do
I do I I'm it's coming back deal with
this Heckler
and then I'm dealing with this Heckler
like I know exactly what to do you know
many weekends at The Comedy Store La
Jolla you know I like I love a Heckler
right and I'm doing well I'm doing well
then I just start bombing I'm just
bombing like the audience is like quiet
it makes no sense that I'm bombing the
energy gets really weird and I turn
around and the host of the show was on
stage looking at the hecklers behind me
going
like shushing them
to try to come out and help me
I'm sorry you don't remember this
I don't remember this
and I've never seen that happen
I mean I've never like even heard of
somebody like came out on stage shushed
and I turned around and truly for the
first time in my life I was
without speech like I could not form
like I could not I was so I was so
stunned
uh that I I couldn't move I didn't even
say anything I didn't even make a joke
it got so awkward and weird and Wild
and then he walked off and then and then
I I blacked out totally blacked out
walks off stage I've tried to clean up
the mess but I'm so shaken I'm so
like insulted and embarrassed uh and
angry that
um he thought I couldn't handle it or
thought I needed his help or whatever it
was and the set probably kept being
horrible uh and then I got off stage and
I was so shaky and you said we're
leaving
I don't know if you saw it or I just
told you about I don't know what it was
but I was like I need to go confront him
like I was irate I was so enraged I was
like I need to go talk to him like the
host he was like went back on stage I
was like I need to go and you're like
we're leaving
and you're why I left and then that
night at the hotel
I called 10 comedians to ask them what
would it take for you to go on stage
while another comedian is performing
nine of them said there would have to be
a physical fight like someone from the
audience would have to have gone on
stage and then Don myrera said I'd have
to see a gun in the audience
wow
you're who you I just remember you're
just like we're like like we're gonna go
this is frightening that I don't
remember this it is a little frightening
but the story is better than I get to
tell it alone
oh I wrote him I'm out of my book
there's a whole chapter about in my book
you're in my book that us going to Dubai
is in my book and uh uh that story is in
my book because it was it was the first
time that I kind of felt the only time I
ever felt like Oh I'm a female cop like
I'm been being treated differently I
never thought being treated like shit in
the beginning was because I'm a woman
all Comics get hazed I never felt there
was sexism at the comedy store when I
started I was like that's just that's
just not true everyone gets put through
that ringer that was the first time I
was like oh you would never have done
this to a guy yeah you think you need to
protect me from this yeah
Were You There When Steve Byrne got in
the fight on stage
and spreader and stories Brad earns to
The Comedy Store no this is The Comedy
Store
no when someone threw a chair at burn
like there's a com it's weird that
there's not more violence in comedy it's
weird that there's not more chaos
it is because the people
what's being said on stage could really
Rob people especially now uh
uh but yeah I I it's been pretty civil
hmm
I think you just get in and get out I
think I do there was a Mark Maron Dove
Davidoff fight from the stage at The
Comedy Store once
I might have told you let's get out of
here because I might not even see anyone
let's go
we're not here you just wanted to leave
[Laughter]
that's just how you leave every set no
we were just driving together the van's
here the van we're gone
that was your first I'll be right back
that's how it began oh my God me trying
to fight this guy
I must have really been in my you might
not have I I do remember I I think you
saw it because I remember being insecure
about you maybe hearing my set or
bombing for you where what do you
remember the theater I can find out the
name easily because I I don't even
remember doing just for laughs uh
Chicago I remember doing it at zanyce I
didn't get a theater spot you did it was
a midnight show it was a midnight show
it was not uh
um it's like a hip it's kind of like a
hipster theater like
um Park West nope
what was it like the first time you sold
out the Chicago Theater that must have
been surreal
or is that so long ago
that was uh I don't know five years ago
that was that was I mean listen for me
to do that in my hometown and then uh do
the United Center there I mean come on
and see the parents
the the Screwed Up thing about that uh
here's something I let my guard down on
which I never do
I had a Nightline interview the night
before doing the United Center
sorry
day off I'm doing Nightline
the night before I go out to Chicago Cut
steakhouse with my family and friends
have a party there we go out to a
nightclub we get a table I know what I
wanted ah I won't now
we got we're drinking heavily
I wake up and what do you drink uh wine
but this was wine and tequila and woke
up with the worst headache talk about
yeah
I knew this was not going to be good you
know like when you wake up I don't know
if you've been hungover recently but
like this is not um
Judy's downstairs in the lobby waiting
she has no idea what's going on with me
Judy our manager who is um the only
person I'm scared of
[Laughter]
so Judy takes me over to Jerry Seinfeld
Jerry Seinfeld is there with a two other
guys eating breakfast and in Chicago
doing the Chicago theater
if you're playing the United Center yeah
you're playing the same night in Chicago
as Jerry yes he's doing four shows at
the Chicago Theater I'm doing one at the
United Center
I come over to him I look like hell pale
sweating
and it was like telling my father you
know I go man I got hung over here
the
night before you do the United States
yeah that's it there goes that
relationship hey so I I go and do the uh
interview it's at my house where I grew
up and
I had to excused myself in the interview
and I had to go throw up in the in the
bathroom
felt so bad so unprofessional I don't
like letting people down they came to
interview me out of state and I'm giving
them nothing
um
and then how much more would you have
given if you were not hungover
I
I would I would at least given them I
mean you don't remember much now I mean
I can't believe I don't remember this
it's really disturbing I'm gonna find
because the theater I now realized has
Rosemont Theater like it I I I'm usually
really good with
shit like that because I do know that
the theater's closed because I sh I was
almost gonna shoot my third special in
Chicago and I looked at the Vic and I
looked at Chicago theater and this place
had closed so I know it isn't open
anymore do you have a good memory
or do you do you Journal
I have an excellent memory for thing and
there's a biological basis for this for
things that were uh traumatizing I know
I'm a white woman that is privileged so
just just throw the word trauma around
like Loosely here but something that is
stressful where your amygdala is
activating you produce cortisol it um uh
holds in your hempo campus more tightly
so I remember everything very Vivid
about this because I went into fight or
flight mode so it imprints harder so we
we remember bad things five times more
strongly than good things like I
remember what I was wearing I remember
my hair like you're it's uh uh like the
trauma response everything like locks in
it's your brain's way of taking a
photograph of everything to keep you
safe in the future wow
so I remember that like negative
experiences very vividly which is what
drives people crazy about women that we
remember like that thing you said two
years ago at that wedding we remember
every you know that but you don't
remember all the good things I've done
and the jewelry I bought it's like well
those were the good things those aren't
as imprinted as strongly wow
yeah no that was that was the only time
that I felt like I let myself down then
and I'll
then I did the show then I did I had to
get an IV of uh what is it the water uh
saline yeah uh yeah so the guy paramedic
came in to give me the IV this is before
the show right so embarrassing it's
embarrassing it's embarrassing so aren't
you embarrassed it's totally embarrassed
put my jacket on and I started bleeding
out my uh no yeah no and I took that
yeah I go guys he goes oh that's not
supposed to happen so I'm sitting there
going am I gonna be on stage in a bit
and I flail my arm and we're gonna see
blood all over the eye
so
how are you David Blaine
so yeah never again never again I think
but I think something was in the drink
because I don't get that way I do not
get that way I don't care like you don't
lose control no
very rare like have you ever tripped in
public tripped
no I don't lose control that was not
good have you ever like leaned against a
wall yeah listen I I I I am a little
clumsy but when it comes is there any
like ring camera footage of you in your
house like tripping like have you ever
drank out of a straw and it miss your
mouth yeah there's been more I guess
yeah
like if you've ever gotten lost
[Laughter]
oh god
um I have to do a when you said you have
a heart out I didn't know oh shit I
gotta go okay I didn't know okay no this
is the best did we get enough uh yeah I
mean
dying to go home I got a four o'clock uh
we didn't even get in okay what I got a
four o'clock Tech run for a corporate uh
zoom zoom corporate Zoom okay so do you
need to borrow some money or are things
tight is it the I mean I know that does
look like uh uh Bruno mogley hoodie
these corporate Zoom uh-huh they're
moderated it's not standing okay no I
did one it was I I halfway through I was
like can I give you the money back I was
in New York it was it was so bad
it was so bad that I was like I you
can't pay me for this
okay so this is to pay for okay okay
this is great because I end these
awkwardly and and Sebastian just managed
to make it more Awkward than I even end
them put like a button on it no I don't
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]